Hello, hello!
I lost track of time because I was playing Minecraft Smash Bros.
You might be wondering, what the fuck does that mean, Doki?
Well, it's basically I climb up and it's smashing time.
That's basically it.
I was doing this.
I was literally doing this the last, like, ten minutes.
Doki, that's right.
Get the fuck out.
No, wait, not me, not me, not me, no!
Okay, yeah, but I was just smashing.
I was fighting a dev.
And I looked at it and I was like, I was like, oh shit, wait.
Wait, it's 2-0-1, oh fuck.
I was like, Doki smash.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
This is Doki smash hour.
I was like, wait a minute.
We have Smash Bros.
in Minecraft?
So, this is what I've been doing the entire time.
I was, like, waiting for it.
Because this never starts in time.
They never start on time.
Look it, we're missing three people.
They never start on time, so I'm like, what do I do?
I'm just gonna explore and I've realized, I realized there's, like, Smash Bros.
I was like, oh my god, I can actually smash.
No!
I died.
I saw this, I was like, Sumo Arena?
The fuck is this?
Also, uh, Saucy Pizza, thank you for the gifted one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I should get my cough drop, I'm so unprepared.
You can't stream this on YouTube?
No, it's Twitch Rivals this time.
So, like, usually on Twitch Rivals, since I got invited for Twitch Rivals.
I'm sorry, I'm playing Minecraft.
I reverted into a child.
I went on Twitch for this.
I'll get my cough drop real fast, I'll be right back.
Okay, I'm back.
So, um, so yeah, basically it's a Minecraft competition.
Again.
Guys, you know that one time I won the...
I won on my first time playing this, and now, like, I'm just chasing the high.
I'm always trying to chase the high.
I'm like a washed up child star, trying to chase that one moment in time in her life where she, like, she was a star.
That's why I always come back.
That's why when they're like, do you want to do it?
And I'm like, oh man, remember that one time I won Black Wars on my first try, and then now I'm going to proceed to lose to every single one of them.
And then I never... she's like, no!
Don't say that!
I personally feel like that Ryan kid in Ryan's world does not want to do this anymore.
Maddie, thank you for the gifted one sub!
Thank you!
So I'm always chasing that high of, like, oh my god, what if, like, oh my god, I hate this.
I hate the Trident area.
I'm just like, what if I could win again?
And then, like, every time I join...
Well, this is the third time I'm joining, but, like, maybe it'll be different, guys.
Guys, maybe it'll be different.
You don't know that.
Peaked in high...
Yeah, my first Black Wars is where I peaked, for sure.
I like how, like, the first Black Wars is where I knew the least of what the fuck is going on, and I win.
And then the other Black Wars proceeding, like, after that, like, I actually know what I'm doing, but then, like, okay, I like how I based my point of reference on that one Black Wars game I did right after, because technically this is my second Black Wars.
This is my second time, like, the third time playing Black Wars, but I can feel it.
I don't understand the trident.
Do I have to be in the water when I do this?
Or, like, I don't understand.
I'm too stupid.
I don't understand the trident at all.
You get close to the edge.
I don't use the trident, so, like, I get so confused.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, yeah.
I just get so confused.
I don't understand this.
Okay, by the way, the difficulty on this one is, like, the very first Black Wars, so we're gonna... Remember that parkour level?
Remember that parkour level that I struggled a lot with the very first time we played Black Wars?
Yeah!
It's gonna be like that.
I get it.
It's gonna...
And, like, you know, there was a trident area part of it, and, like, you know, it was not pretty.
It was... It's not a beginner lobby.
By the way, this lobby is actually pretty fucking intense.
Like, I was looking at it, and I was like, bro, what the fuck?
Almost everybody here is, like, a Minecraft player.
And I'm here.
And there's me.
Oh, hey, it's, like, sumo... Ah!
It's okay.
It wasn't gonna take me anywhere anyway.
That's the sumo area.
Okay.
Uh...
Okay, so, yeah, it's literally the same thing.
There's the order up.
There's party.
Like, literally, we played all of this before.
Yeah, but we're better now, guys.
We're... We're better now.
We know what to do this time.
This is different.
Okay.
Oh, wait, everybody... Oh, wait.
Okay, I'll join the VC now.
I'll be back.
I don't know if I have sound guy awake or sound team.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, I have a team now.
I don't know if sound team is awake, though.
Let me join the VC real quick.
Hello.
Hey, guys.
Are you guys...
Good morning.
What?
It's the fuck you guy.
Which one?
There's multiple?
You.
Wait, me?
Why am I the fuck you guy?
No, no.
You kind of made me think of the fuck you guy.
Wait, who's the fuck you guy?
Who is the fuck you guy?
Who's the fuck you guy?
Wait, who?
Wait, I'm so confused.
The boogeyman.
Who's the boogeyman?
Dookie.
Oh!
Sorry,
I'm a little slow.
Wait, I might be thinking the wrong thing because we were meant multiple people.
I might be thinking, Kumi, there's multiple fuck you guys, so I might...
There's multiple fuck you guys in...
Kumi, I think, like, you know...
You gotta be very specific because you've like...
There's multiple fuck you guys in your dictionary.
Is it the...
You know, the fuck?
The fuck you guy?
You're gonna make me throw up.
I feel sick.
Or the...
Fuck you guy?
What is wrong with you?
You gotta be specific!
There's multiple!
It's the...
Fuck you guy.
Okay, but like...
Wait, no, you gotta...
Is it the...
Fuck, fuck you guy?
Or the fuck, fuck you guy?
Oh, it's the...
Fuck, fuck you guy.
Oh, okay, I know who it is.
I was just thinking.
Oh, okay.
Then I don't know then.
No, I'm pretty sure you know who it is.
If you're saying you know who it is, then I think you know it.
Yeah, but there's...
But there's multiple here.
There's at least like...
I think there's like seven.
Yeah, yeah, I was gonna say that.
Gumi, I think like...
I think like...
One of them is on our team.
Yeah, chill.
And he's seven right now.
Fuck you guy number one.
Guys, look, we have ugly sweat.
Is this an ugly sweater?
I'm worried it's not supposed to be an ugly sweater.
And then I called it ugly.
I'm sorry.
It is a very pretty sweater.
Christmas sweater team.
Right?
Oh no, we're like wearing winter clothes.
We're like little elves.
Wait, I have a ponytail.
I have like a mistletoe.
On my head.
I have a ponytail.
Look, there's a mistletoe, Doki.
Wait, where is it?
It's not a mistletoe.
It's on the back of my head.
It's a hat.
Anyways, it's a fucking hat.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't want to become a fuck you guy.
I'm scared.
Oh my god, who are we waiting for?
We were all here.
Let's start the game.
Who are you interviewing?
Who is it?
Why is it not us?
Or me?
What the fuck?
I think you are the fuck you guy.
All I'm saying...
Is that anybody should be interviewed.
I don't have an ego or anything.
I'm just...
Yeah, I mean, you have a 100% win rate, right?
No.
It wasn't my fault.
Let's just say...
I actually did pretty well.
Individual wise.
What place did you get out of...
Like...
20th?
Yeah, I'm like...
Average.
I'm just average in Minecraft.
Which is pretty good.
But it was like...
My second time playing.
I'm gonna watch you doing parkour.
Please don't.
Parkour is actually...
The only thing I can't do.
What are we waiting for?
I feel like you asked that two minutes ago.
And it's still the same thing.
The interviews.
Yeah, but like...
Who...
I'm gonna call them out.
On live, on stream.
Oh wait, I shouldn't.
That's our teammate.
Why did they pick her and not me?
No, I'm joking.
All I'm saying is that...
If they went up to me...
And was like, I wanna interview you.
I'll be like, if you wanna interview me...
You gotta interview the whole team.
I can totally imagine you saying that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll be like...
I feel like...
This is a team effort.
And because it's a team effort...
I want my entire team to be here...
For the interview.
That's all I'm saying.
Don't tell our teammate I said that.
I think I've been reporting something to my teammate...
That you've said that.
No you won't.
I can...
Blackmail...
I can extort you.
Yeah, you do.
You see that ticket over there?
It would be a shame if I...
I don't even drive, Doki.
No, you see that...
VIP ticket over there?
It would be a shame if I just...
Changed the name.
Changed the name on the ticket.
Oh my god, she is the fuck you guy.
She is the fuck you guy.
You're just like the other fuck you guys.
For those who are wondering...
For those who are like...
What the fuck are they talking about?
So like, you guys know that there's...
The Streamy Awards.
So like, apparently everybody...
That got nominated...
Gets to go to the thing...
Because you have to be there.
But like...
I like how Gumi was like...
Oh yeah, really?
What is that?
Even though she's like part of it.
Basically,
Gumi was like...
Oh my god, can I like...
Can I like hold the tablet?
So like, because I can't go.
So I was like, yeah, sure.
So basically, Gumi is going in...
In my place.
But she's holding a tablet of me.
And I'll also be streaming...
Silent Hill 2 on that day.
So you just message me.
And in the middle of my stream, I can call in.
We'll be at the red carpet.
In the middle of my own Silent Hill 2 stream.
We'll be in the red carpet.
And I'll just be like, hey guys.
I'll be like, intermission.
Intermission right now.
So we're going to have to be at the red carpet.
Hold on, chat.
I gotta be on camera for like 5 seconds, guys.
So we're going to be doing it live.
But yeah, Gumi...
I asked if Gumi could go in my place.
And they said yeah, as long as they like...
Hold my tablet of me.
Because the camera's going to pan to her.
When they like...
Say the nominations.
And also...
When she goes to the red carpet.
They'll be like, who are you?
And she has to say Doki Bird.
Because it's literally in my name.
Wait, I can't say Doki Bird's butler or something?
I mean, you can.
You can if you want.
Just say whatever the fuck you want.
But you gotta make sure that they know you're going for me.
Dude, I'm going to have to download a GIF.
And have it playing on repeat on an iPad.
And say, oh yeah, this is her.
I can literally call in.
I can literally scream.
Not the entire time.
You're going to be playing Silent Hill.
No, I'm stopping in the middle of Silent Hill.
I'm going to be stopping in the middle of Silent Hill.
And call in and be like...
And then like, you know, QT would be like...
Hey guys, like, who's this?
And I'll be like, hey QT.
I'm just passing in the middle of my Silent Hill game.
Just to be here.
You know?
Do you have a script?
Do you have like a script written out already?
Each of you will.
Like on the red carpet.
Like they're interviewing you on the iPad.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello.
Hello Hannah.
Hello, hello.
But yeah chat, this is what I meant when like...
I can literally revoke...
I can change the name of the ticket so she can't even get in.
Dude.
Actually they changed that.
You're not allowed to mess with the form anymore.
Because do you know why?
Last year people were messing around too much.
And kept swapping names and stuff.
Oh.
Yeah, but I'm new.
So then they'll just be like, oh maybe she made a mistake.
If I do it once.
Evil, evil.
Gumi, are you on Lunar right now?
No man, I don't even...
Shayna's doing something crazy right now.
That's all I'll say.
Lunar?
The fuck is that?
It's a Minecraft client where they get to emote.
And I think Ampross is actually the fuck you guy doki.
There's so many.
No, no, no.
But not like the fuck.
Like fuck you guy, but like...
Oh, fuck.
Fuck you guy.
Oh.
And I'm watching him fuck you guy another fuck you guy.
Oh, wait.
BL?
Yeah.
Wait, where, where, where?
In the middle of spawn.
Oh, okay.
I'm coming over.
I can't miss that out.
I see it.
No he's not.
It's because we can't see it doki.
They have a special client.
We don't have the glasses.
We have a special fuck you guy client.
Damn.
He's twerking.
Oh, no, no, I see it.
Now I see it.
I see it now.
Dude, I think you're lying to me.
No, no, I see it.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, no, I see it.
I have it specifically downloaded just for this moment.
Oh, okay.
Man, I love Minecraft.
What are we waiting for now?
I don't know.
My tab is a little bit broken.
I think everybody's on.
Start the game.
I don't think it's going to matter.
I think they updated the map a lot.
I don't know how much it actually matters.
I'll watch it right now.
Fine.
There's no way.
They would never update the map.
They'll keep it the same forever.
You would wish that.
I don't want to learn a new map.
You just follow people.
That's all you need to do.
No, that's too hard.
You just look at the shoes and follow them.
That requires me to use my eyes.
What else are you doing?
Instinct.
Pure instinct.
Is your bubble icon thing working okay?
Yeah.
Bubble icon?
The discord bubble...
I don't know.
I'm using my own.
My own link.
Yeah, I think they use bubbles instead of boogies.
What the fuck is a bubble?
No, I don't use boogie.
I use discord.
I don't use... yeah.
Hello.
Testing.
One, two, three.
Guys, I'm getting antsy.
And when I get antsy, I'm gonna turn into a fuck you guy.
Okay, but what would you do as a fuck you guy?
Oh, I would say fuck you.
So that's just regular you.
What?
That's just regular you.
What's the difference?
I barely curse, man.
Oh my.
Okay, let's see.
We're starting.
That's the ready.
I actually don't know how it's tabbed out, but yeah, we're starting.
It's tabbed out, but like I think so.
I'm just adjusting my sound right now.
Oh.
Fuck you guy.
Alright, Ant, I'm watching the video.
Okay.
What are we watching videos of?
You should, like, screen share it for me.
Oh, race?
Okay, I'll screen share it for you.
There's a race.
Honestly, we should play this game first if we can.
I don't know if it'll happen.
We should play this game first.
I don't think it's gonna be first because they always vote order up, though.
Yeah.
We could do this or temple first.
I'll burn.
Whoever gets the fireball, burn the order up area.
Wait, for the order up, are you and Hanna going to be in charge of crafting ant frost?
I'm okay with whatever.
Yeah.
We're good at simple tasks.
I'm a very simple girl.
Yeah, that's fine.
Somebody's gotta be on, like, mushroom duty and getting a lot of mushrooms so that we can get the upgrades.
Alright, SK, that's your job.
I like mushrooms.
Oh, I forgot about that!
You start off with it and do the Feinberg strat and you start off getting all the mushrooms.
Okay.
Then if I do that, then SK should just grab a ton of apples instead.
Apples.
Because we need a lot of apples as well.
SK, you've played blockways before, right, Miss SK?
Nope.
Oh, no, but she...
You just need to hit the tree leaves in the apple area.
There'll be a little apple icon on the map that you'll see when you look around.
You see trees?
You just hit the tree.
I will smack the tree.
It's like Minecraft.
Yeah, I saw you play Minecraft Civilization.
I know you got this.
Parkour Civilization!
Yeah!
I'm a parkour master.
Not to flex or anything.
Wait, did you finish it?
No, I didn't.
I got pretty close though.
Wait, why did you stop?
The server was lagging and then I had to play Street Fighter.
I need to go back though.
Yeah, you're just gonna give up like that, SK?
I need to realize my dreams.
You're right, I'll never be a parkour champion if I just give up that easily.
Yeah, exactly.
What would he say?
What would the guy in that video would say if he sees you like this?
He would say I'm weak.
I can't have this.
You might as well just leave Block Horse right now and boot up Parkour Civilization.
Wait, Ant, were you watching my screen?
Yeah.
Okay.
Guys, I might go do that.
I know this is gonna change a lot of the map though, so I'm not sure how much of the map will still be the same.
Yeah.
I don't really know how to play it.
Okay, so when we get into Tomb Titans, what is your plan for us?
We need to find the portal.
Yeah, I think just like staying semi-together is a lot better than splitting up for the most part.
Because the mobs are sort of scary.
It's very easy to die to the mobs.
Really?
I thought the mobs weren't that bad.
I think we split up with teams of two.
It depends on where you are.
Sometimes the mobs will get you cornered and then you just can't get away.
There's a lot of skeletons more than anything.
Yeah, because when I was with Finebrae, we split up and I think we did really well in that part.
I think splitting up is fine as long as somebody can get to you if you happen to die.
I'm so scared for that game.
I'm fine with Tomb Titans.
I've played that game once.
I have no idea what I'm doing, to be honest.
I know nothing, so I hear nothing.
Oh, the tomb thing is darker and darker.
That's basically it.
Yeah, it's literally dark and darker, but like Minecraft.
Wait, you've never played dark and darker?
No, I really should.
I've played Tarkov.
Is that the same?
Yeah, it's kind of similar.
Basically, you pick up a lot of pots and items and stuff on the floor killing mobs and if you want to avoid other players and dying.
Well, no, other players can't kill you unless you're in the big zone, right?
I saw something about vases.
Breaking vases.
Yeah.
Is there a boss area that you can die in?
Yeah, it's just the boss area.
Dude, what if she wanders in there?
I'm just gonna die.
There's a giant fucking troll in the middle, she'll know.
Dude, there's a giant fuck you guy in the middle is what Doki said.
Hey, everybody's a fuck you guy.
It's lost its meaning now, Gumi.
It's lost its meaning.
Do you know what the worst part is?
I was referencing a TikTok when I said fuck you guy, but you just rolled with it.
So now everyone is a fuck you guy.
Wait, this is the place from Squid Game.
What?
Yes.
Oh, these are the new players.
Yeah, mine are too.
Eski, that's you!
Eski!
That's you!
Is that it?
Oh, there's two new players.
Oh, that...
Oh no, there's only two new players.
You know what that means.
What should we do?
Nothing.
Oh, they also have the gingerbread man.
Oh, and then there's Shadow.
And then Shadow.
It's a Wall-E bear.
Wait, what should we do?
Of course.
Shadow.
Oh, elves.
I think I'm throwing it back on the ladies.
Where are we next?
Oh, we are!
Yo, check it out, guys.
Wait, are they...
Wait, Metal Sonic is there.
Metal Sonic?
Yeah!
Oh, I like how she was on the same skin as last blockers.
That's funny.
Oh, it's so cute.
And now to the donut.
Oh, that's like the picking.
We're gonna pick.
Okay, what do we want?
Race?
This is so cool.
Or tomb, yeah.
I feel like we want race.
I think we want race too.
You're really good, but I'm kind of...
We're not a movement team.
I just exist.
Battle, order up.
Everyone's already going to order up.
Our best games by far are battle and blitz hunt.
Guys, I don't think race is gonna win, guys.
Guys, we're moving to order up.
No, no, no.
Don't grieve, don't grieve.
Guys, I don't think people are gonna vote for race.
I have a cat voting for it.
Don't worry, plus one cat.
Wait, I'll get all the cats.
Plus one cat.
No, cat, no.
Come back.
Come here, cats.
Wait, how do you die in the voting stage?
You get hit.
Wait, wait, wait.
We might be able to do this, guys.
No, come back.
No, my god, Kabuto, stop.
My cat, no.
They picked me up.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm okay now.
I think it might be order up.
It's always order up.
They don't like change.
Change is bad.
Is anyone going to be on delivery?
Ant, what's up with that?
I mean, I can do delivery if you want, Hannah.
We can craft together.
I can just do delivery as well.
Is that efficient?
That's what Feinberg made us do.
I think having one of the cooking people also deliver is good, I think.
Yeah.
Oh, Gumi, what did Feinberg say for you?
For us, just three of us were gathering, and then him and the other fellow was crafting and delivering.
The other fellow.
Don't even remember his name.
I only remember you and Feinberg.
Okay, then why don't me and Ant just craft and deliver, then?
Yeah.
I think eventually, once we get enough resources, maybe Gumi can move into the kitchen as well to help crafting.
We will get overwhelmed eventually.
We'll need to do more delivery than anything.
Okay, so who's going to get what right off the bat?
I get cows.
I'm the farmer.
I'll go get fish.
I'll get fish and plants.
Oh my god, milk time.
I can get some of these plants and...
Crops, maybe?
I'll get mushrooms.
Um...
And whoever's getting the cows, get all the animals too.
Gumi, can you get the sugar cane and the fish if you're going to be by the river?
I'm 90% sure sugar cane is by the river somewhere.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I've seen it.
We should get the furnaces first-hand because it's lava buckets in them now.
You don't need coal anymore.
Oh, okay.
So we should upgrade that first.
You should upgrade everything.
So get all the mushrooms.
And then...
Does someone get mushrooms again?
How does that work?
At a certain point, I could just go back and get more if we need some or I can ask for somebody to get some.
And remember he didn't put all of them and he split them a little bit.
Yeah.
When we see that it's going to open up again, like the composter will open again, we can just have... we can get mushrooms real quick, I think.
Hey guys, where do I go for the apples?
Oh, you go straight.
You see the trees in front?
You look up.
You hit the tree.
SK, you see that?
That's a tree right there.
Oh, there's a big apple above it.
Yeah.
If you break the leaves, it'll just give you apples.
I know it's your first time seeing a tree, but that's what it looks like.
Wait, let's take a look at what is first to be made.
How about I do...
I don't know.
We need a lot of pork chops and we're just going to bake a lot of things.
Yeah, so once you kill all the animals, come back, just put them in the chest and then go kill some more.
I think focusing pigs would be good.
Okay, pigs?
Alright, no problem.
I'll make sure no more pigs are alive.
Should we bring a small batch back first?
I would just get a lot.
I'm heading over.
Five seconds, guys!
Once you get like 20 apples, maybe come back and then you can go back out for some more.
Maybe when you come back, you can make the golden apples and then put them in that chest.
Oh!
There's free gold on our farm.
Get down.
Don't worry, guys.
Where are these boxes?
I feel like I'm missing something.
Oh, these pumpkins.
I'm a troll.
I have acquired apples.
I'm bringing oranges back.
I'm going to come back when the composter is active, okay, Hannah?
Okay.
I don't really know what else to get.
Don't worry!
I've got some meat!
Whoever has meat, if you want to come back now and just put it in the furnace, go for it.
Did you get sugar?
Yeah, I'm bringing it back right now.
I put meat in the furnace.
Perfect.
I'm going to come back in a second, Hannah.
I'm going to get some more furnaces and we'll start going.
I'm dropping off everything in the chest.
Okay, I'm coming back now.
Goodbye, animals.
Yum, yum, yum.
Rush order.
We have rush order.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
That was me adding to the composter.
Don't worry.
I got a lot of levels.
What's the rush order?
20 apples.
I've got more meat.
Okay, so I have a stack.
I got some more cold apples.
Meat time, meat time.
Pork chops are done.
Is there any other specific stuff you need?
I'm grabbing fish.
We need baked potatoes as well.
You can bake the potatoes.
Potatoes going right now.
I don't know.
Someone get a lot of pumpkins.
I have five pumpkins.
Can I start putting raw meat in?
Can you sugar?
I got it.
I need more eggs.
If anyone can come back with eggs.
Sorry, I fell off the ladder.
I tripped and fell.
I'll go get eggs.
Okay.
How am I supposed to get up to this person?
Don't worry.
Here I go.
I have many things.
Oh my god, sorry.
You're fine.
I can go faster than you, so it's fine.
Okay.
There's 10 eggs in the chest now.
That didn't launch me.
Okay.
Why did that not launch me?
Hey, this is my job.
Are you taking my job?
Why are you taking my job?
We didn't miss it.
I was just very bad at my job.
I'm getting crabs.
What do we need, squad?
Can I grab mushrooms?
I'm grabbing them.
Do you have the baked potatoes?
Oh my god.
Okay, can you put the baked potatoes in 2 and 3?
And?
I got 5 potatoes.
I'm coming over.
Maybe get another smoker, Hannah, from one of the upgrades.
Oh my god.
This is fun.
I feel alright.
I think if somebody wants to get a bunch of mushrooms for the next upgrade, that would be good.
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm going to take your job too, SK.
Okay, okay.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I'm going to deliver this, Hannah.
Oh my god.
For the cakes, we need a lot of eggs.
Alright, go do the eggs.
I got mushrooms.
I'm bringing back 2 stacks of mushrooms.
Hannah, whoever got the mushrooms, can you put them in the composter?
They're in the back.
There's still a bunch of oranges in the chest.
It'll be active in a minute.
Do the same one.
It is active.
Hannah, do the rush order.
I'm working on it.
I get apples.
Okay, I'm bringing back some more eggs before I come back.
I'm getting lemons.
I'm making the cakes.
I love being a farmer.
It's so chill.
I know, right?
I'm stressful over there.
I'm just a humble farmer.
Hannah, you got that.
I'll get it in a second.
I love farming.
Where's this customer?
I don't have enough wheat.
I don't have enough wheat to make this.
Oh, we need wheat.
It's trolled.
The rush order is trolled.
I'm getting cows.
It's okay, we don't need those rush orders.
Yeah, we don't need them.
I think we might have needed it.
I'm looking at our placement.
I brought some more wheat back.
I'd like to get more.
I got some more upgrades.
Do we have any deliveries?
No.
I got the apples.
Do we have pork chops going right now?
We have a lot of chicken.
I got pork chops.
Is there anything we really need right now?
Can you deliver that?
I got more fish.
Should we buy another elytra?
If we get more upgrades, we can.
I don't know how many points it is though.
Why is...
Here's some more fish.
Guys, you're asking what team are we and you don't see my name.
We're not even on the leader.
Okay, you go get the wheat, Goomy.
I'm getting mushrooms for this.
Rush order is definitely the most important thing to focus on when we can.
I go get...
Can you deliver the rush order?
I get more fruit.
Do you guys need more pumpkin?
Probably.
I go get a pump.
Jesus Christ, who's in Phantom?
Wait, Goomy, can you put some stuff to cook in the cooking things if possible?
I don't even know what I'm trying to do.
I'm going to make the mushroom soups.
This is like Minecraft aim trading.
Porkchop and chicken?
Do we have porkchop and chicken right now?
Yeah, in the chest.
This one's done too.
We have a lot of resources for something.
Just put it in the composter.
I'm supposed to put mushrooms in there, right?
Yeah, mushrooms is good to put in there.
I'm going back with some...
Whoa, some veggies.
Hannah, buy Elytra.
Potato and pumpkin pie.
I can do pumpkin pie real quick.
Hold up.
I need wheat.
Yeah, I just put some in there.
Pumpkin pie.
We need five big potatoes.
Oh my god, I'm so lost.
Do we have big potatoes?
I got more meat.
I thought we had a lot.
What, two minutes?
We have a minute left.
It's okay, I got some more wheat.
I'll make the golden apples.
I'll make it.
I mean...
Hannah, do you want to deliver that one?
Yeah.
Do we have lemons?
I put the lemons in.
I can do six lemons in here.
What do we need?
We need mutton.
I put it in already.
I'm going to deliver.
Oh, new restaurant.
I'll do the mushroom stews.
Can anyone work on the other thing?
I think right now meat is our main priority.
Can you get more wheat?
Yeah, I can get it.
I'm jumping over.
Where are the oranges?
I'm grabbing wheat now.
I grabbed all the wheat.
I'm here.
We have a minute left.
I'm doing deliveries now, by the way.
I think we have a lot of resources.
Can I just put wheat down?
We have 21.
I think we need to focus on orders now.
We have so many.
I got it.
If you want to help with the orders, you can.
We have a lot of resources right now.
What do we need?
Order 2 can be delivered, right?
Oh my god.
One mutton in there.
I did it.
I look and I'm a little confused.
Anyone need me to deliver something?
I'll make the golden carrots.
I'll make bread.
I'm confused.
Me too.
What did she give me to deliver?
You can deliver.
You can deliver it now.
Nice.
I don't think we can add anything else in.
That was rough.
The numbers mean.
You almost had first place.
We're 7th.
That was hard.
But 4th place has 25 and we have 24.
I know.
We just didn't get the rush.
They have more rush already.
It's all about rush already.
It's purple.
We'll get it next time.
We'll just keep the water view that one.
It's a good thing we got this game early.
I think we want tomb and race as well.
I thought the race was the hardest one.
What do you mean?
Race is just like...
I don't know.
It's like experience.
This game is cute though.
Honestly, all of those...
I don't know.
We'll see.
I think we can do final race though.
I think Hannah will get a top 10.
You don't like it?
Sure.
I'm here for a good time.
Confidence.
It benefits teams that might not be as Minecraft experienced.
But in battle, we're going to absolutely destroy everybody.
I'm sorry, we are.
We actually are.
What is race?
Is it like a race?
It's like parkour.
It's what you've trained for.
Oh, yes.
I've been training my whole life for this.
Yeah, you've been training for this.
Can you turn down the Minecraft music?
Yeah, I think.
Yeah.
It's good music, but it's so loud.
Alright.
Wait, where am I on the leaderboard?
We have seven minutes.
There's a cute guy in my room.
Let's fucking go, guys!
True.
We're above the other team with the new player.
Exactly!
We're above...
Isn't Toppo the Minecraft player?
We're above that guy.
He is a Minecraft player.
This is true.
Oh my god, we're above Toppo!
Oh shit, am I going to get like flamed?
As an individual who is not a Minecraft content creator, I don't know much.
Oh my gosh.
Dude, he is a Minecraft dude.
Oh my god, I'm better than a Minecraft dude.
I play Apex.
Dude, you just...
I don't learn.
I learn nothing.
Hello Kazoo.
Kazoo, get the fuck you guy.
No, you don't understand.
There was a giant fly in my room during order up.
Wait, do you have like...
Do you have something open?
What do you mean something open?
Okay, why would there be a fly in your room?
Are you living like...
Because my door was open.
Oh, I was going to say, are you living like...
Asmongold?
You know, like his room?
No, but I...
I literally told Efron to essay this.
But...
My younger brother, he was raising maggots in his backpack.
And we found that yesterday.
So like, there's a long...
Oh, that's like...
Like...
I'm surrounded by fuck you guys.
You were just raised like that.
My neighbors live like Asmongold.
So for six months, I was just having flies on my desk.
Oh my god.
Until the exterminators got like a warrant to go inside their apartment and clean it up.
Wait, is he a hoarder?
I don't know.
There was like a bunch of tiny fungus flies around me at all times.
That's crazy.
I'd be playing Overwatch tournaments and there's like three flies in my field of view.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
You were living with fuck you guys.
It was so bad.
Sounds fucking terrible.
Oh my god.
Hey, but at least the rent was cheap, right?
No.
You'd think it would like lower the rent, you know?
Like if that was your neighbor.
Oh.
You'd think that.
Hello, Miss Husky.
It seems I found you once again.
Hello.
We always end up in the same place.
Start the match.
Match found.
Ah, fuck you guy.
I'm so sleepy now.
Gumi, not everybody can be a fuck you guy.
If everybody's a fuck you guy, then that's not special anymore.
Who said it was special?
The world is made out of fuck you guys.
Gumi, are you okay?
Why do you ask this every time we hang out?
You know why.
Have you watched the new Wicked yet?
I have and I've sadly watched it in 3D.
What?
Dude, you didn't watch it in 4D?
If you watch it in 4D, you move along with all of the creatures.
It was not fun for me.
It was like super vibrations.
It was like you're on a fucking rollercoaster.
I'm just trying to be like, please, I want to know what's going on.
I don't need a rollercoaster ride.
That's actually crazy.
I've never even seen a place like that.
Just look at 4DX movies.
It's really fun.
It's like the ride moves every time someone flips their hair or whatever.
Yeah, you can control the vibration.
And I put it at 1 and it was still so intense.
And I'm like, bro, they're just walking.
Why am I going through turbulence on somebody walking down the stairs?
Dude, it's immersion.
I don't like that.
So I had that and 3D.
I forgot how muted the colors are when you watch in 3D.
Oh, really?
Yeah, because the glasses are tinted.
So the colors are less vibrant.
I thought the movie was actually really good.
I think it's good, but I feel like I would have enjoyed it more if I watched it not in 3D.
And not on a rollercoaster.
Yeah, maybe.
Doki, the immersion though.
I was definitely not immersed.
Oh my god, are they interviewing?
I swear I'm going to fucking tab.
I'm going to tab and see who's in the interview.
I'm going to call them.
There's no one in the interview corner!
What are you waiting?
Nobody's getting interviewed.
No one's being special.
Dude, they're doing a hashtag ad right now, Doki.
Wait, are they?
Okay, but is it a good ad?
Wait, I got kicked out.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean it.
I'm sorry.
I'll never say that again.
I'm sorry, I got put in the timeout corner.
Alright, oh my gosh.
When are we going to start the next game?
Woooo!
I'm impatient.
Oh my god.
We're definitely not starting.
We never even started the timer.
What do you mean?
There was a 6 minute timer going.
There was a 6 minute timer?
And they paused it.
It was wild.
I was surprised.
We're being held hostage.
You guys, sorry my mom called.
I gotta leave.
Nevermind, JK, I'm here.
Hang on, I found your mom.
I'm down for Team Titans as well.
Alright, I'm on race.
I managed to die last time in the voting section.
Oh my god!
I just saw somebody get stabbed!
I stabbed him.
It was me.
Wait, which one do we want?
Team Titans, honestly.
What the purple?
Let me go!
No!
It's a fucking bomb!
Who did I vote for?
Oh, I wanted to party.
Let's go.
Where are you?
I'm partying right now.
I'm partying with the cool kids.
With the winners.
Wait, we're the winners.
They're literally two ranks above us.
No, no, it's okay.
Alright, it's time.
It's Dark and Darker time.
Awesome.
Alright, I'm gonna go with Goomy.
Oh, this looks like Dark and Darker.
Yeah, but wait, you've never even played it.
How would you know?
We could have been gaslighted.
We've been gaslighting you this entire time.
Oh, true.
Dark and Darker is actually very bright and happy.
Oh!
Make sure everyone's brightness is on 100% because I was an idiot last time and didn't have it.
Bright and brightness.
Yeah, but then how would I be immersed?
I don't know.
Oh, true, that's very important.
That's true, you gotta be immersed.
It's still really dark.
But is it Darker?
If we find the boss room, if both of us are there, we could do it.
We'll wait for Feinberg to roll up and then steal it from him.
So Ant, the merchant, what do we do?
We sell our less good loot or something?
Yeah, so if you have a full inventory and you need to sell loot and you don't want to leave yet, you find a merchant and you give him all of your least valuable stuff or stuff that doesn't stack and sell it to him.
I'm not even gonna lie, I have a feeling in my bones that I'm about to sell, so maybe we should all try and stay close together-ish.
As long as somebody can get to your body, we can res you if you don't die and somebody else loots you.
I think the main thing is making sure that eventually you work your way into the middle enough because the map decays, right?
It's sort of scary if you're at the outside.
I would say going through this room, we should go straight ahead.
What if I go left?
If you go left, just make sure that you know where to go inwards so you don't get caught in the decaying room.
How does the shield work?
That's the map.
You can remove the map from your opponent.
It only has one or two durability.
It only takes a couple hits before it goes away.
It has to be in your... okay.
You don't have the opponent, you can just hold it and block with it if you need to run away.
There's no sprinting or anything in this.
It's all just a set movement speed.
Did you think the map was our shield?
No, I was trying to hold the shield and the map and it's just like jumping up and down on my screen.
We're all going through.
If you break those or you kill mobs, it'll drop loot and it'll have a little money value on them.
The better...
gems are worth a lot of money and they stack.
Higher tier armor is worth more money.
Do we have to sell everything before we leave?
No, if you go through the portal, it auto-sells.
Yeah, so when you go through the portal, whatever you have on you is banked as money.
But if you have a full inventory and the game is only halfway over, you can go find a merchant and sell some of your stuff.
It's a discount, so you're not going to get the full value, but that lets you get more stuff to take out later because you have more inventory room.
Should we split like three and two?
I think we can split up a bit.
As long as you aren't getting cornered by mobs, you probably won't die.
So just be aware of where you are and where the mobs are around you.
I always kill mobs before I loot stuff, generally.
But there will be candles on the ground, so if you need to find a portal to get out, look for the purple candles.
You just want to follow them as they get bigger and bigger stacks.
It'll start as one, and then it'll go to two candles on the ground and three and so on.
But they don't spawn until later on.
Yeah, so to get out of the portal, you have to go to the middle of the map.
So we're not going to split for that now.
I think there's candles for the merchants too.
There's like cyan candles or something.
I don't know.
We'll be fine.
I'm ready.
I'm ready!
Doki and I are going slower together.
I guess I have to follow Doki if I feel like it.
Yeah, you follow me, I'll lead the way.
Okay.
Watch this.
If you get better armor, you can put it on if you want.
Like, gold armor is better than sort of better than leather.
And if you need torches to see, you can put torches down.
Just make sure you put them on all of you too.
Oh, this is fun.
Oh shit!
Wait, these guys are stronger now.
Hey guys, hey, Gumi, why did you run away from me?
Where are you, Doki?
Oh no.
Gumi, Gumi, Gumi, please.
Gumi, I went in there hoping you'd help me.
Where are you?
Nice.
It's already over.
Where are you?
No, but I might.
It's okay, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Gumi ran away from me.
I was literally in the same room that you told me to go in.
No, you're not.
I see you.
Oh, there's a creepy staircase.
There's another, like, weird button here.
Which one do you want to go down?
Here's the middle.
I don't know.
Left.
Left is promising.
I'm just swapping my equipment.
I don't know what left is.
Wait, let's go down here.
Okay, okay, I'm coming.
Doki, I'm here.
Fuck you guys.
That one needs more loot, right?
Ooh, I found planets.
Alright, I got him.
There's another fucking guy over here.
This music is so freaking loud.
Yeah, I approve.
I might need to turn that shit down.
Do you want to come down here?
Yeah, let's go.
I hear spiders.
I'm a creepy guy.
That's better armor.
Doki, I opened the door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's go, let's go.
It helps you survive a lot better.
That's fine.
There's better armor.
Oh my god.
We have to circle back.
Oh, no!
I died next to you.
Want to go this way?
It's okay, we keep all our equipment.
I think you need to crouch next to Doki and you can respawn.
Hannah, do you know?
Yeah, you just have to- it's like Fortnite, I think.
Yeah.
It's okay, we keep all our stuff.
Oh, you gotta keep crouching.
I'm just being revived, but then you stop.
I see you stopping.
Oh, I have to hold right click!
Oh, okay, I didn't know that.
I haven't revived someone before.
Sorry, I've never revived someone before.
It's okay, no.
It's okay, we know now.
I think ladder can't.
I forgot these guys are stronger.
Yeah, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Hannah, you can get a lot more gems from them, by the way.
Wait, I'm pressing the door.
Doki, there's an evil per- What do you think this button does?
I'm okay.
Oh, look, there's a thingy in here.
Oh, there's another button over here.
Yeah, press it, press it, press it.
Something good is gonna happen.
Watch this.
Do you want any potions?
I'm good.
Oh my god, gold!
It's gold.
Do I wear the gold armor?
I'm going up here, just for a sec.
I'm gonna turn down the music, it's so loud.
It's really loud.
Yeah, I turned it down.
There's another button, should I press it?
Yeah, press it.
Do we go this way?
Look, this is where I died.
There's a boss room in front of me.
I don't know if any of you are near me, but...
I'm here.
If you guys are still on the border of the map, by the way, you probably want to start moving your way inwards.
It's a little scary to be on the border when it's okay.
Okay, we'll move inwards.
Hannah, we can do the boss the other hand if you come to me.
Okay, let's move inwards.
I'm trying to figure out how to get to you.
Okay, this way?
Coming over.
We have to go this way.
Where's my body?
I think the door is under me.
How do I get down?
I wish it was more intuitive of how to go up and down the map.
Maybe this way.
We're following me.
Awesome.
Now what?
There's like three skeletons behind us.
We're inwards.
There's so many.
We're figuring it out.
We're so smart.
Oh, I got one.
I just need pants now.
I see some of you guys.
There's a lever.
Let's go.
Wait, if you guys...
Um...
I have a villager.
I have something here.
If you have extra stuff you want to sell Hannah, that's worth doing.
Can we sell our armor?
Uh...
Extra armor you can sell, yeah.
There's so many things down there.
Look at the prices and try to sell the least valuable stuff first.
Don't go down.
Don't go down, Gumi.
The clay shards are good because those stack.
I found the boss room.
Um...
Gumi...
I went down.
What do you mean?
I told you.
I told you not to go down.
But I was stuck down.
Do you see the white room?
The white outline?
I'm going too high, I think.
I don't really know what's going on.
Gumi, where are you?
Gumi and Doki.
I'm saving Doki.
She's saving private Doki.
There's a chest right there.
Nice.
That's my other tombstone.
I can't, I don't know.
Yeah, there's another tomb.
Okay, I'm going to be more careful for real.
I promise.
If you're too high and you can't find a door for it, it's probably like...
Wait, what's stronger, iron or chainmail?
Wait, maybe we have to go up here?
I found one.
If you're not towards the middle, you need to move your way in a little bit.
How do we get up?
We're like in the boss room.
You're a different one from me.
One of you needs to aggro the boss, and the other one needs to crit it out.
Okay, we're in the boss room.
Whoever aggroes the boss, the other one can just...
Oh, Hannah, I'm here with you guys.
I don't know if the boss is in here or not.
I don't know.
Let's go down and see what's going on.
Let's go down.
I'm going down.
I'm going down with you.
As long as we both find...
Oh wait, as long as we both find the exit together...
I'm not sure if I see anybody.
I'll be careful.
Oh, I...
Watch out, PVP!
Oh, shit.
Let's kill them.
Hannah, I'm coming.
Yeah, kill them.
Kill them, kill them, kill them.
Oh, I can't.
Of course.
Okay, let's just go into the boss room then, I guess.
There's like 20 things in here.
Wait, this is PVP area.
Okay, I'm not even going to entertain that.
That's so dumb.
There's so many.
And my inventory is full.
What should I do?
We have 4 minutes left, so we should try and find the exit.
Should I find Merchant then?
Yeah.
Wait, there is a boss!
It's an Iron Golem!
Guys, guys, guys!
Oh, we're coming over.
Whoever has the Golem on them should run away, and the other person should just kite and try and get it.
Let's start critting out the Iron Golem.
In a second.
Oh, sorry.
Run, run, run.
I'm running.
Well, I'm getting shot at by the Skelly.
Nice, Kimmy, you got that?
Yeah, yeah, we got it.
We gotta find the exit soon.
Behind you, right here, right here, right here.
We have 4 minutes, guys.
We have to find the exit soon.
No, bro.
They're out, they're out, they're out.
Oh, no!
I don't even know.
Team PVP is down.
Team PVP is gone in a little bit, by the way.
Be careful.
We should find a way out then.
This is the portal room.
So look for the purple candles on the ground, guys.
And that will lead us to a portal.
I need more, like, high value stuff.
Okay, so what...
There's some potions here.
This is where Ducky and I came from, no?
Yeah.
Okay, Ant, we have to figure out the exit, like, right now.
Yeah, well, we have a little bit of time.
I'm trying to figure out...
I'm going in this room over here.
Oh, there's a candle here, there's a candle here.
Okay, everyone come over here, if you guys can.
And also, drop your leather armor, if you have it.
It's, like, really useful.
It's, like, worthless.
Leather armor's bad, stone tools aren't really worth anything.
I have, like, gold.
That's fine, I have inventory space.
So, we need to find these purple candles.
We found, there's one candle here.
Yeah, there's some real stuff in that room.
Yeah, there's two right here.
The portal's right here, the portal's right here.
We need to find a button for it.
Is there going to be a button somewhere?
Unless it's not open yet.
Okay, the portal's not open yet, so we need to remember how to get back here.
This is how we're going to get back here, okay?
This is how we're exiting.
You can stay in the area and look for loot, but this is how we're getting back.
How does that sound?
There's, like, a...
I don't know what that is.
Is it a warden?
Does chainmail armor sell for anything?
Uh, you can hover over it.
It sells for two, it's not that good.
There's nothing.
Get rid of, uh...
I don't even know.
Are they torches?
Torches don't really sell for anything, so...
Oh, my inventory's not full, I think.
Yeah, try and make it, like, as full as possible.
Like, iron swords are a lot better...
than chainmail.
I think iron and gold are the most valuable.
Oh, there's another portal right here.
There's another portal right here if we need to get out.
Nice!
Potions are good for me.
Um...
Let's also use arrows.
I just don't think arrows are really that valuable right now.
Oh, portals are now open!
So, as long as... make sure that you know how to get back to the portal.
Is the portal by me and Doki?
Doki's behind us.
Yeah, is there, like, anybody can...
Oh, there's peasants here.
So, like, it's not one use, right?
No, no, no, it's not one use.
That's good.
There's a lot of mobs right here.
I'm, like, freaking out a little bit.
Is this the boss room?
Oh, this is the boss room.
Uh, I think the warden's in this room.
I'm a little scared to go in this room.
I don't know if you guys want to do this or not.
I think it's a little scary.
One minute!
Woo!
Game over in a minute thirty.
Um, I would say grab any last minute things and then go find your way back to a portal.
Alright, I'm heading over.
There's a portal down here.
Okay.
Let's get all these things here and then we'll go back.
Alright.
Awesome.
Oh, there's an emerald here.
Purple is here.
Doki, pick up that potion!
It's expensive.
Okay.
Uh, chain mail.
I mean, if you don't have anything else to grab, I would say so, probably.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Okay, Doki, let's go back here, Doki.
I'm gonna come to you.
There's a portal right where we just were, Doki, in that room back there.
Whoa!
I got shot at.
That scared the shit out of me.
I'm going in!
Goodbye, guys!
Nice.
We have so many points.
Yeah, but that's three of us.
That's three of us dropping in.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Yay!
I think we're the first full team out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so we'll see how the other...
We got out.
Yeah, no, that's it.
The main thing is that we all got out.
I think that's really important.
Yeah, yeah, no, last time I...
My last block was I did not get out.
I also got locked in the first time I played this.
So, uh...
It was already an upgrade.
By the way, there was a boss.
Wait, Red has not got out.
Red team is still all in.
They're probably trolling.
Yeah, they're trolling.
Yeah, they found it.
No, actually, two of them don't.
Yeah, two of them haven't found it.
We did good.
Yeah, we got four.
Yeah, the scores are super close too.
We actually, yeah, we did really good.
Oh, what happened to Lime?
Oh, no.
All I'm saying is I might have died two times, but we got out.
Yeah, that's okay.
You got res.
Oh my gosh, I was so focused.
I was a little bit stressed.
Oh, there's a tomb warden in here.
Oh, that would have been fun.
No, we saw him.
We saw him and we walked away.
Okay, we're no longer in seventh.
We're climbing.
Let's go!
Look at us go!
It's really close points anyway, so...
Yeah, I'm fine with that.
I think that was good.
I was really scared about that game, to be honest.
My one time playing it, I got locked in, so...
Yeah, me too.
Yeah, we didn't get into any decay or anything.
Okay, an alleged three minute timer on the side.
I don't know if that's going to be true.
Yeah, at least it's not seven.
It's not seven anymore.
Oh, thank God.
I apologize for any sick noises I make.
I'm dying.
Me too.
I'm dying of bed as well.
Yeah, I've been sick for three months now.
I know.
Oh my gosh.
You need to message me back about what I last asked for.
So I can find it for you.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Oh look, I got 19 plays last game.
Wait, who am I above?
Guys, look at the people I'm above.
Look at all these minecrafties.
Oh my God.
Nice.
Oh my God, okay, SKN12.
Wow, SKNGamer.
Go to spawn.
Alright, individual tab.
Oh shit!
Middle of the pack, let's go.
Being average in a minecraft...
minecrafter filled lobby is pretty good.
Poor green.
Yeah, I would say poor green.
They had a rough run, I guess.
Okay, but guys, don't worry.
We still have battle.
True.
Battle's gonna be like 9000 points, guys, so don't worry.
last block wars, I almost took my team from like 10th to almost 2nd.
Like 4 points from 2nd.
There's 18.
Because of that.
What happened to the other two teams?
Guys, it's just me.
She locked in for that one.
She locked in.
No, guys, that was just a special event.
Like I was doing really, really good that day.
Wait, stop.
Stop.
That's so bad.
I think... I mean, honestly, as long as race isn't the last three, I think we'll be okay with everything else.
Maybe split, I don't know.
I think race...
I think everybody's trying to make race the last one.
Yeah, I hope not.
That's a scary game.
Yeah, it's just like...
I don't know.
Well, it's like a map that a lot of people here have played before, so like, it's not good for us.
I feel my life force draining away each break we have.
Oh, my God.
Oh, guys, six seconds left, guys.
Let's go.
Oh, my...
Oh...
I'm gonna lay in bed.
Yay!
Let's go.
I can't even lie.
Oh, my God.
Okay, who's gonna...
I have a TNT.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to blow up one of them.
I have to place the cat.
I have a gully.
No!
I'm going here.
I'm gonna blow up this.
Chat, which way?
Oh, okay, battle.
Okay, don't go where Fruit Brace is.
I feel like that's battle.
Okay, that was a terrible... I thought the TNT would be like 20 kills or some shit, but I guess I was wrong.
I'm freaking out.
Okay, I'm fine with either one.
I don't really...
Oh, Extractions is...
Rainbow Six Siege, let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just shoot.
I forgot if it's hold or... Is it hold?
I forgot.
Miss Esky, you should pop your pussy on this one.
I will pop my pussy.
This is reloading, right?
Yeah, you have to reload your crossbow.
Esky, because I don't know if you watched a whole... You probably did, but each person has like three hearts or something and you shoot them with a crossbow and then three times and they're dead.
And then you have to leave through the center through a helicopter in the middle.
You have to crouch in the middle and you get extracted like an alien.
So do you want more kills before you leave or what?
Yeah, you want kills.
You want to live.
It's team versus team, so it's 5v5.
I mean, kills are good, but also extracting is also really good.
So if you're like 1 HP and there's four of us and only one of them, you should just hide until we kill them.
I see.
It's just Valorant, but like without the thing.
So yeah, it's like a set one heart and you... Oh, it's CSGO.
There you go, it's like CS.
I mean, they have scope bombs, they have health up, which will give you an extra heart.
Is either left or right is the health up?
I don't remember.
How do we split?
I think either like 3 and 2 or we all just go on one side.
Should we all go on one side?
I really like one side.
Last time I played on this map, one side, it was not great.
You got split up.
I think being... Split up and high ground.
Yeah, I think playing high ground and doing a 3-2 isn't bad.
Especially if they all go one side, it's a lot easier to flank if we have people split up as well.
I wish we could have the crossbow out now so I can see the reload.
And SK, the crossbow reloads like instantly, basically.
It's pretty fast.
What was the ping?
You'll get used to reloading and shooting really fast.
What's the swap offhand key?
Oh, press F.
F, F, F.
F is the default.
You can ping.
It's like Valorant ping.
If you see somebody.
Ms. SK, this is just like Valorant.
And the middle is the spike where we have to go, but only if we kill people.
Or you can sneak in.
Most of the time.
Okay, where do we all spawn?
So like, practice the crossbow.
I think Kumi, is this you next to me?
I'm next to Hanna.
Oh, you're next to Hanna.
Do the two of you want to go try and flank on the side and the three of us stay over here?
Hanna, I think I'm going up here.
I'm gonna go right side.
Hanna, go on that side or play towards middle.
There's health either left or right.
We'll play on the left.
We'll play on the left side.
Left is health up then.
Rush for it.
Go, go, go, go.
Alright, Kumi, I'm following you.
Nice, get the health up.
There's three right side.
Oh, I got hit once.
We need to help them.
Try and get a flank off.
They're on me.
I'm here.
I'm looking.
I'm going behind.
Did you bomb me?
I don't want to die.
Joe is right here.
I got Joe.
He's two hearts.
I hit one.
I hit him.
They're all on me.
I got surrounded.
It's okay.
They're all pushing you.
Sneak is two.
All four of them together right there.
I don't know if the flank is clear.
Sneak is one.
Shadow is one too.
Try and target the people that are low.
I'm one heart.
We're in their spot right there.
Whoever is hiding here, you have a one.
Sneak is one.
Nice.
Good shot.
Shadow is on the opposite side of the map.
You're going.
I got Joe.
I'm middle.
You see the last one.
You guys start checking.
Hold on crouch.
I'm crouching.
No!
It's okay.
We won the round.
Good work.
It's okay.
We won the round.
As soon as they killed Anthos, they turned around and killed me.
I'm far left.
I'm going up the stairs again.
I think Hanna and Gumi do the same thing.
I'm going right side.
I'll scout.
I'll look around where they are.
Where's the extra heart?
It's on the far side.
I need help.
Just heal Hanna.
They got health up though.
I'm an idiot.
I don't know where they went.
I don't know either.
I'm trolling a little bit.
I might die.
I dropped.
I'm heading over to Anthos.
I see him.
I got Pete's four hearts.
I'm caught in the middle right now.
I don't like this fight at all to be honest.
I'm already taking two hits.
I don't know where they are.
I'm just trying to...
I died.
There's a guy right here.
There's two guys.
There's three on me.
Careful, Gumi.
There's three behind me.
I'm dead.
There's two here.
I bumped into them.
There's three people.
I think it's full HP.
I didn't hit one of them.
I hit the reload off.
I don't know how to play this map.
There's so much...
It's high ground.
I don't like parkour so much to get up.
I think just playing high ground is better.
Maybe we should just play for high ground.
High ground is the best.
I think maybe high ground middle.
I think high ground middle might be good.
Be wary of your sides I guess.
Gotta get the health.
Go for the health.
I'm running left.
I think.
How can we go left?
I think we come back and go to middle after.
Where's the extra heart?
I see it.
There's three.
I may be dead.
I don't see anyone over here.
There's three or four of us.
We should push back a little bit.
I'm gonna try and flank behind them I guess.
They're all grouped up.
What?
They're all together in a spawn.
In their spawn?
They're coming through middle.
On SK right now.
Two of them under you.
That smoke fucked me up.
I got confused.
Someone's extracting.
I can't shoot her.
There's three.
Five versus one.
I'm trying to find a way around.
Five versus one right here.
SK there's one chasing me behind you.
They were literally...
They just all stayed together as five and pushed.
That was unfortunate for me and SK.
There's one on you right now.
They're coming from our spawn.
They're coming from our spawn to your left right now.
They're coming that way.
They're not extracting.
There's too many.
Maybe if flanking five is working.
We just got run down.
We can do that.
I think pushing together.
I think whoever is closest to the heart should try for the heart.
And then regroup.
I agree.
We can maybe all...
I'll get the heart to the right.
I'll get left heart and then go right.
Everyone else goes right.
I don't know if I can do it.
You might want to go to the middle and flank right instead of going to the heart.
It might be scarier to go for it alone.
I'm coming with you.
Oh my god.
He got it.
I got it.
I couldn't get the heart.
And there's like one person.
Two hearts.
I'm coming over.
Five up is one.
Get five up.
They're shooting through that smoke.
I'm one heart.
Try and play your life right now.
I'm playing for my life.
I don't see any.
I'm chilling.
I'm fighting a 1v3 right now.
It's bad.
I'm one.
We're all one.
I got shot from...
I didn't see you.
Oh no.
There was a flanker.
No.
It was a flanker.
Should we go the right way?
The same way?
I don't know.
I think so.
We should have one person at least flanking.
I think we have one person lurk towards mid.
And then everybody else should go the same way, I think.
Yeah.
I think let's go the same way.
Right?
I think we go right.
Doki, can you run right and I'll grab the smoke.
Yeah, sure.
This map is so awful.
This map is hard.
Sorry, map.
Oh, I'm not looted.
One right side.
Volibear and Kabuto on right.
Nobody grab the heart.
I'm grabbing the extra heart.
Hold on.
Mia has two hearts.
There's someone over here.
There's a bear here.
That box is one on you.
Yeah.
Nice.
What if I go extract right now?
That would be so sweet.
Put it on him.
Nice.
Good work.
Everyone leave.
Good shots.
Yay.
We did it.
My god.
That worked pretty well.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We're just waiting.
Okay.
We have one more round.
Wait, two more rounds.
Oh my god.
She just sneaked out.
Who's still alive?
It's pink versus orange right now.
Oh.
It's a 1v1.
They're the top performing team.
Right?
I'm on the far side.
You guys should go right.
Okay, I'll run for the power up.
I'm right behind you.
Haha.
Shut up.
Oh my god.
I see him.
They're all in the middle.
We're shooting for you.
I see right under you.
They literally all went through mid.
I got shot by three different people.
Holy shit.
I'm backing up, SK.
Above you.
There's two of them.
I'm getting the extra heart.
No one got it.
Radoon's on you.
To your right.
Nice.
One more above you.
Radoon's coming from there.
They're both there.
Nice.
Nice try.
Yeah, you're the last one.
I got shot by three different people.
All random people were spawning and killed me.
I didn't even have time to get away.
That was unfortunate.
My bad on that one, I guess.
Yeah, I saw one guy and apparently I was in view of three different people.
Yeah, I don't know where we should be going.
I don't know if it's better to play up high and mid or...
How about we all go up high?
We could try all going up high.
We have one more round to try it.
Yeah, last round.
Last round.
We got this.
Oh my god.
There's a huge gap.
Between fourth and...
Fourth up and...
I believe...
I mean...
Right?
We're going to the right?
I would just go towards the middle and go up high maybe.
Honestly, there's platforms up high that you can get up right here.
There was.
I don't see anyone in the middle right now.
Oh my god.
Got the health up.
There's one left at least.
They're all here.
I see among us.
I got Bricky.
Among us guys, three hearts.
Purple does four hearts.
What the fuck?
These guys are MLG.
Jesus Christ!
Wow, they're crazy.
I know, I got shopped.
Back to back to back.
Yeah, I got sniped.
Where's behind us?
I killed two.
Purple is one.
I got purple.
I see him.
It's only him left.
Nice!
We did it!
Let's go!
My god.
I locked in.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Hey, we got fifth.
It's not so bad.
We'll take that.
At the beginning, we struggled a little bit, so...
We picked it up.
It's just like a rough map.
I think the visibility on this map is so hard.
Because it's...
I think they changed a little.
They changed this map a little because I played it last.
Last block wars.
Yeah, because last block wars was a lot cleaner.
To be fair, it was the baby block war.
The baby.
The baby block war.
Baby.
Woah.
The gap.
It's actually not that bad.
You can make that up in one round of battle.
That's...
What if...
What if we...
What if we get like...
Don't even say that.
Because me and Ant on the same team in battle is diabolical.
But isn't there like...
I don't know, like five people in a team?
No, but like...
I'm saying that because last block wars...
Ant did insane and I did insane.
That's true.
Alright, my standards are gonna be very high now.
I'm gonna have very high standards in battle.
I've never PvP'd in this version before.
What?
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Wait, I'm higher ranked than Kumi?
Let's fucking go.
Make sure you're not sprinting.
You let go of W or else you can't crit.
Do you know what I mean?
What?
I know what you mean.
Wait, you have to let go of W?
But my brain didn't know that.
Wait.
Right before you want to get a crit, when you're mid-air, just let go of W for one half second.
That's how you get the crunch.
Instead of the regular hit.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Hey, Kumi, check the leaderboard.
Weird.
Hey, Kumi?
Let's go to the Sumo arena.
On the compass.
Oh, that's the Smash Bros.
Alright, SK.
Wait.
Five minutes?
There, you got it.
I didn't actually know that, but my hands do it.
Which is super weird.
I bet, yeah.
That's kind of how it was for me.
Nice.
Yay.
Why am I jumping so high?
Oh, because it's Smash Bros.
I don't even know.
What is this?
Whoa.
Wait, are these real people?
Or are they just bots?
They're real.
Oh, the staff people are real?
Can't believe it.
Four minutes?
Are they interviewing someone?
No, they're not.
They're not interviewing anybody.
Alright, I muted myself for a little bit.
I need to fix the volume a little bit.
Guys, this is so sweaty.
I think it's like 90% actual full of Minecraft.
90% Minecraft lobby, I'm pretty sure.
Why am I here?
I'd never say no.
Yeah, this is very sweaty.
I cannot say no.
Let's see who I'm better than.
Oh, guys.
No!
Wait, no, that's last game leaderboard.
Okay, but look at this.
You might be better than me at last game.
But in the overall leaderboard, I'm still up there.
It's fine.
Oh, no.
Race is scary.
Race is worse.
Race is where we might have forgot how to play.
Let's go.
Wait, what's his tournament earnings in Minecraft?
Do Minecrafters win money?
I feel like they just make so much money in general.
I don't even know if they make money.
Tournament earning.
Oh, shit.
Esport earnings.
9,400 from 7 tournaments.
Alright, guys.
He has 9.7k from tournament earnings alone.
I got that Liquid PD I pulled out.
That was a weird way.
Minecraft streamers make so much money overall just from like content creation.
I'm just like wondering do they have tournaments with like winners?
To be fair, I did play the Haunted House.
OrisaBongo?
Two or three shot people, essentially.
It's like giving your whole team like Ana ult, essentially.
If they're within the range of it.
Yeah, and they respawn so like your power up.
So you should do it at our very first fight and then like the next fight that you have it.
They're all like one shot though.
So you have to like put them in spots where it's hard to shoot them or kill them.
Do they go through walls?
Yeah, it'll do it.
It's just children spend a lot of money.
There's like a 5 or 6 bucks radius around it.
Children market is like the most, one of the most lucrative market out there.
It's not actually fighting people.
It's having really, really good positioning.
So you're a team that makes it to the very, very end of the game.
Look at Ryan's world.
Most of the time I'm just going to be like, guys, follow me, follow me.
Because I'm always going to like try and put us in a position where we're not right next to a team.
Oh, Battle Royale, we're playing Apex Legends.
Yeah, essentially, yeah.
I think I was watching a video.
I should listen to this.
We'll have an easy way to get a good position.
But yeah, just follow me.
Try and hold hands and stay together.
Try not to run off.
The only time I've ever run off was to go and kill Fruit Berries because I was... and I paid the price for it.
So I will never do that again.
I was watching a video about Ryan's world, and like he made $30 million in a year.
Within like this last year.
He's made $30 million within last year profit-wise, which is...
Oh, yeah.
How many numbers?
Isn't that fucking insane?
Yeah, because it's like...
He merchandises hard now, so he has like lots of toys and stuff.
And kids are like...
Because parents will buy stuff for their children no matter the price because they're like, we want to make our children happy and stuff.
So, what is his content?
He basically does like toy unboxing and stuff, and he's like 14 now, right?
So people right now, the biggest controversy is that people are like wondering
if...
People are like wondering if he's like too old for this now because his content is entirely for kids, but like they're like, are his parents forcing him and shit like that?
Is he 14 or 13 or younger?
Wait...
How old is Ryan?
I know he's like a tween right now.
I know he's like a tween.
Wait, which currency?
Uh, the hourglasses.
Oh!
I was close.
They just refreshed the shop too, so you can buy like, they have like the monthly...
Yeah, I bought out the monthly ones already.
But yeah, like, that's what people are talking about right now because like, they're like wondering if it's like oh shit, Ryan retired?
Because like, is he actually doing that because he enjoyed it?
Or like, is he doing it because his parents are making him?
Because I mean 30 million dollars in a year?
That's insane!
And like, and like, his channel they don't even use they don't even use his like, his like newer content, because like more children watch his videos when he's younger so they purposely reuse his older content and it works like 30% of the time they reuse his older content to like,
entice children to watch the videos more.
Because like, they don't click on the content where he's like obviously 12 years old versus like, you know 5 I don't think so Because like, people who are 12 don't watch Ryan's world anymore like the audience that grew up with him will not be watching his channel now Yeah,
basically, they already grew up grew out of it, so like, he has to like he has to like, attract the newer children
Event paused?
What are we pausing for?
Every time I I always look at the interview channel They do!
They have, they have he has two younger sisters Oh shit Wait, what?
Sorry, I was talking about Ryan's world in my chat The toy review?
Yeah, yeah, the toy review You know, he made like 30 million dollars last year For sure Yeah, I was watching a video about him Cause like, right now they're like, trying to be like, should Ryan retire?
Cause he's like 12 now So it's like I've seen so many posts about that Yeah, yeah, cause he's like Cause they're like, wondering like, does he actually wanna do it?
Cause his content is like, entirely like, geared towards like children, cause the audience he grew up with outgrew his content So like, they're like, wondering like oh, should Ryan actually retire?
Because like does he actually still wanna do it?
Retiring at 12 is crazy Yeah, retiring at 12, I mean he made 30 million dollars last year Like Just from one year alone Like he's set for fucking life if he invests it Yeah, sometimes like I don't know I heard his like, mum or his parents, like keep making him do it,
but like bro, he's he's literally a teenager now, like no one wants to watch him review toys or anything Yeah, yeah, like toys that are like for like, like 5 and under Yeah I know, but sometimes it's like never enough, like you know what I mean Like when you,
probably when you make that much money it's probably never enough for them They wanna get more and more They're just like, they're accustomed to the lifestyle type, yeah Yeah, cause I was like watching it, and I thought he was like like, but like, and he's like he has like multiple like sponsors and like brand deals and stuff like that,
like like merchandising and things It's actually crazy how, like I didn't even know he had a Nickelodeon show Really?
Yeah, he has a Nickelodeon show called, I don't remember, it was like Something Ryan, it's always Ryan something It's...
It is always Ryan And he had like a a movie this year like in August that released I mean, it got pulled after like 3 weeks cause like, no one watched it No Like, um, apparently they like, it was like a 10 million dollar production, and it got pulled after like 3 weeks or something It was called,
it was called Ryan's World I watched like a little bit of the movie cause I was curious, I was curious I was like, I was like this was in theaters?
Like
Holy...
Bro, I was curious of parkour civilization like, why are you watching that?
No Oh, I love that guy Doki only wanted to watch it for the beef or chicken and then left afterwards Gumi literally told me, she was like she was like, the only good part was the chicken You said that to me You said that to me Guys, I'm gonna go to a race I'm gonna go to a race They were talking about speaking in parkour How do you read parkour?
Well, clearly you're not meant to be a parkour master, you can't read it Clearly not!
There is parkour language Yes, see?
Oh, shit!
No, I died!
Everyone stay After I watched it, I went on a flight international, and the flight attendant asked if I wanted the chicken or the beef and I was like, no Wait, wait, wait, battle might have won Oh my god Race!
Let's go!
No, I lost Let's fucking go I died I died for your sins Okay,
so Do you start and go straight right or straight?
For the start, you go to the right and then afterwards, you'll get an electric handout You wanna fly up to the jump pad on the white Is this normal movement?
Wait, do we go straight or left?
I didn't listen Go to the right Yeah And then after that you'll get an electric at the end You wanna fly to the white afterwards So you start on the right At the end, you'll get an electric and you can fly for a bit Alright, my goal is not last, guys I hope you guys do better Do better so you can make up for my placement No,
we got this
Oh yeah, I hope I don't No, I will absolutely get lapped, guys A bad pause No, no, no Oh wait, there's two laps Oh my god, there's hope, I will get lapped There's only two laps?
Yeah, it says two on top We got this There's hope There's hope for me It's a long map It's a long... oh This has to be a new map then, right?
Uh, it's not It's a long map Um I guess this map has always been two laps, I guess When you um I don't even know what I'm trying to say, just forget it Let's try to hit the little red speed pad here and then you wanna jump over the soul sand and go to the left Oh JK JK Maybe somebody sneezed and pressed the button
Can you relog to get the resource Oh, they don't have the resource pad Wait, and so I'm supposed to jump over that soul sand Uh Yeah, you go for the diagonal jump over it, I think Is that allowed?
And then I think after I think you wanna When you're gonna get on Elytra, you're gonna want to fly to the top of the white over there You see like the further white platform I don't know what that means You see like the white stairs on the left Yeah You wanna fly to that On the second lap You're gonna have an Elytra And you're gonna fly to that Are we going left or right at the start At the start go right Why can I see froggy I can see froggy as well,
I don't know why I think like Her thing is bugged maybe Yeah, I see that Oh, cause like they re-logged They logged out and re-logged
I wanna just push Them out It's fixed
Call the race What Oh my god Oh my god, it's fixed Oh shit Yeah Lock in, lock in, lock in I'm so locked in It's speed boost Okay
Whoa Should've taken the short But I got scared
Hmm No, I hate this area
I hate that gold
No, I hit the thingy Oh this is all new, oh my god
This is all new, I don't know where to go
Cool I'm following Shane, he knows the way But does he though Oh, that's glass Oh my god, why would they do that Wait, it is?
Oh my god, it is Why would they make that glass
Wait, no, I don't wanna go to the hard path No
What if we just skip that next lap
Hey Tubbo
Oh Oh no, I'm throwing, I'm selling
I'm so locked in Yeah, you guys are so locked in Wait, how come I can't Oh no, I fucked up I was not locked in, guys Oh my god, guys, I saw what I think Well, actually, that's gonna be time I was definitely not locked in Oh my god, I'm selling Okay, that's good,
nevermind
And how are they moving so fast That's so hard, that's actually so hard
The way that hard path was barely worth it, by the way I don't understand how people move so fast
Oh, that's how
Oh, do I just run?
Oh Okay
I realized I could've just ran I actually made myself slower by jumping
That makes sense how I got lapped there
Things make so much more sense now
Yippee Jesus Christ, this is a long map I'm already, oh my god This is the first lap now
Wait, where am I?
Oh no, oh no This is bad, I fucked up I shouldn't have taken the medium path I got confused
Everyone's so fast This is where the real minecrafters are We're just plebs in this world I like fucked up
For charity, remember This is all for charity Oh my god, guys, guys I fucked up, guys You got this?
Oh my god, I actually fucked up there
Guys, I'm so sorry
I think I hate this map
Everyone's so fast I know my place
I'm just surprised I could recover this much I'm sorry Oh no Okay,
now I know I won't make this mistake again That's fucking right
Okay I need skimmers to stop Everyone's so good I feel like I'm going so fast, but I'm so far behind
Oh no, the boat, not the boat Oh, these bushes slow you down Oh my gosh Not the boat, anything but the boat
Okay Okay, I didn't do so bad Oh wait, that's amazing, good job Yay Guys, don't worry Come on guys, keep it up, keep going Don't worry guys, as long as I'm not last There's hope for us I'm 38 by the way Yeah, we were so close to each other Oh my god Alright,
keep going guys Wait, are we all done?
No
I'm gonna spec you I told you I would watch you during race, I told you I would watch you And I didn't deny it I know my place I know my place in here I'm an easy type girl Yeah you are I tried medium and then I was like That ain't for me Nice, you passed these people Yay,
not last Let's go That was really good Guys, 37th, it wasn't 38th It was 38th I had it It's okay, Ant I literally I Like, half the time I used to try it It just didn't send me far enough Yeah, me too I don't know I don't think I could have done any better than I did I did good I genuinely like,
I don't know what I fucked up I fucked up because there was that part Where you're supposed to run instead of jump That long icy thingy And I jumped The entire time Until I figured out you're supposed to run Don't worry That was very unintuitive It wasn't very I was like,
why is everybody faster than me That was so cool I wanna play it again Yeah You did so good Wait, what did you get, SK?
16 Woah Nice Look guys, we got fourth What the fuck is this gap though Oh my god Because purple has two S tiers Wait, that's not fair Tell them to Tell them to Wait, are people tiered?
Yeah, they're tiers Oh yeah, I know My place
Okay, what happens to me after Oh, it's okay Everything's fine Cuz Oh no, everything's not fine It's another seven minute break Like Wait, why do we need breaks though Is it for like ad breaks Audience votes on the next event Sleepy beat me
Wait, who am I above though You know what, that's fine It's fine, I'm not last I can redeem myself in the next one Oh my god, I'm so proud of how I did There was this like really really hard jump SK, did you go for the hard path Like the ice neo thing Yeah I went for it twice I made it past the neo,
but then I fell Oh yeah That's fucked up Oh my god, like There's another pretty hard one I don't know The one where you have to jump on the skeleton heads are always kinda hard There's a skeleton head I felt so cool doing that one I messed up all the tridents though I've never used it before Yeah,
it's okay Next time, next time Top ten No, literally the first time I played Race, I think I got like 35th Or something insane That is so crazy You got 16th Yeah, she did parkour civilization Of course she did She's flexing on me She has the shout of the hedgehog skin She's a twos Log out and change to sonic skin
Dude, and we have eggman on the blue team too Wait, what if Guys, what if I swap skins right now We still have 6 minutes You should Alright, I'm gonna do it Yeah, honestly Alright Um What is the premise of this new sonic movie Shadow Is it a new sonic movie?
Shadow Oh my god, wait, I know which sonic I wanna be I saw a trailer, but I had no idea what was happening When this guy with a mustache came on And then he shaved his head or something I was like, what?
That's Jim Carrey That's Eggman
That's Eggman How do I download Oh my god You never watched the sonic movies before?
No, are they good?
Yeah, they're actually really good They're actually one of the better gaming movies Alright, guys I'm gonna swap my skin real quick I'll be right back What is she swapping to?
Wait, what should I tell her to vote for?
On the twitter You'll see Nothing matters to me, I'll play any game Nothing matters Okay, wait, let me decide Where is this tweet?
I still can't find it Oh, it's on the Twitch Rivals Channel, I think Maybe vote party Where's my block?
Oh, there it is Yeah, like the skeleton head Parkour part was such a bad skip It wasn't even worth it What was it?
Was it like not even a shortcut?
Yeah, it was not even a shortcut It was just hard It's just to flex people Just be like, yeah, I did it I did that particular mode It's so bad Wait Wait I'll look I can see you, are you RoboSh...
Dude, I was just playing Pokemon And I see your eyes spawn into my face I'm Sonic.EX
Very cool
Did you play?
Are you going to roleplay right now?
What is happening?
Oh no, I launched the wrong game Wait, where's the poll?
It's on the Twitch channel Twitch Rivals I'm on it I just launched it Be careful
Wait, where's Shadow?
Oh shit!
SK!
What kind of Christmas miracle is this?
Oh my god I don't want to see what happens Wait, you should be Amy or Tails Oh my god We have three minutes Either Amy or Tails Let's just be a full Sonic Let's just swap clothes Amy, Minecraft, and Sonic Hedgehog Hedgehog
Wait, are you roleplaying?
Alright, be right back Oh my god, okay I'll swap to the Tails If you're going to be Amy, then we'll be a real Sonic team I'll do Tails, Minecraft Tails, Minecraft
Tails, Sonic Oh my god, where is it?
Minecraft skin Oh my god, how much time do I have left?
Tails
Oh my god Oh my god, we have to have everyone's chats vote party Oh, it ended Okay, I'll be right back Wait,
I'll be right back
Party won What happened?
That's so embarrassing What happened?
I went to go look for the poll And I was looking for it everywhere I looked on Twitter, I looked on Twitch, I looked everywhere And it's on the screen Nice And then you have a poll And I bet like ten people probably voted in that There's no way I don't even know Oh,
I think we're doing party Oh, party, let's go That was ridiculous Let's get sleepy We gotta get sleepy in our team now I'm here now, I'm here I'm here
The whole gang is here
We should be here
I need Sneak to come here Where are we missing?
Where's Eggman?
Where's our Dr. Eggman?
He's coming, I need...
Sneak
Nice We request a new team Mods
They're gonna do it
What the hell does Amy even say, bro?
He's like...
You're just here to chase after Sonic You're his girlfriend
Asterisk blocks Eggman with my hands
I love roleplaying I love roleplaying What do you mean?
I love roleplaying Alright, are you guys ready for party?
Yippee I love this game, it's so much fun Which one are we doing first?
Party
Oh my god It's loading Do you know the paintball game?
I'm writing a really long roleplay right now Kills are good Getting the roof and ceiling is really good Roof and ceiling?
That's a thing?
Yeah, sometimes there are blocks above Hey guys Do you like planes?
Oh my god guys, we can run into the void Wait, come here I'll see you on the other side
Why are we roleplaying in the chat?
Guys, I just invented a new technology It's called a cell phone It can have games I don't know how to do a triple neo You have to go to the corner like this This just makes me upset You go to the corner, you have to aim right here And you have to run for like a slight second And then just full send it around
I've never learned this before
How do you see my shadow?
This is terrible You think this is allowed?
I can't do it I just can't do it I'm not even going to try I'll try one more You don't want to move your mouse until you're around the block Essentially Dude, I think I'm doing it to the seat You're going to double jump And then you move your head You move your head after you're around And you want to turn in This is horrible All you're going to do is run for a slight second And then you You just hold spacebar You don't have to time your jumps or anything Just hold spacebar and send it This is horrible I don't want to do that again I can't even do a double Oh my god I'm watching this You can do a single and a double I believe in you Hurry,
Tails Join the tree
This is the real content Yeah, buddy We're Shadow and Doctor We've got to make the full train
Join the tree That was rough
I don't think Shadow wants to join Shadow just wants to play Shadow's dad
I'm getting a little bit freaked out I will find the chaos hammer
That was fast
Nice!
Splat!
Wait, bandit, Dr. Eggman's missing one player.
Yeah, I think generally, I mean, we don't like fully split up.
I think like we just try and claim like maybe one directional corner maybe.
Maybe we can like be like southwest or something.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think working towards the middle is good as well and you can get kills.
Yeah, because I think people are going to forget about middle.
Yeah, I agree.
And kills are worth a lot too, so.
Yeah, I don't think I'm gonna kill.
You can throw a little bomb and it'll cover the whole area with your color.
Whoa!
Yeah, so SK, to like reload your gun when it's out, you just shift on your own color.
It's like Splatoon, SK!
It's literally Splatoon.
It's like Splatoon!
Okay, we want more land?
Yeah, as much as possible.
I got northeast.
I'm in northeast.
I think we should all try and do southwest.
Okay.
Yeah, there's already really southwest right now.
I mean, we can split up if we want, I would just say.
Just go north-south.
Okay, I'm done.
And we have three people.
No, Ant, maybe three of us start southwest.
I'll go middle.
I'll go middle, Ant.
Because no one's in southwest.
Like, no one's around here.
Okay, we can split.
We can split if you want.
Except for purple.
Northeast time, let's go.
Let's go purple.
Straight down.
You can't kill your own teammates.
There's no team damage.
What the fuck?
Bro, I got like instant...
I got instant red.
It started?
Yeah.
Lock in.
How is that not killing?
Oh my god.
Oh, nice.
I got it.
Get him, Antfrost, behind you.
Oh, I'm on the top of a building.
That's OP.
The movement is so weird in this.
I feel like you can't do the tech use ability before.
Yellow has a whole corner to themselves and nobody's going for them.
Okay, let's try and figure out any corners that aren't taken, maybe.
Fruit berries!
Purple is getting all the roofs and it's very effective.
Yeah, I know.
I think it's a good shot getting on the roof if you can.
Try and get any corners that you guys see, like, unused.
Oh, you can get stairs.
I just noticed.
Yeah, like, if you're scared you're gonna, like, die, just go in a corner.
No, Fruit's just on me from behind.
You just can't?
Oh, guys, we're running out of time.
Whoa, there's a...
Oh, a bomb?
Oh, if you guys have a bomb, make sure to place it.
I honestly don't have a bomb.
No, Eggman, no!
Keep going, guys, keep going.
Lock in, lock in.
We're doing really good, we're doing good, we're doing good.
Purple was one?
I'm just kidding.
Oh my god, like, why are two oranges just running around together?
Oh, no.
I don't know how I'm getting killed there.
Okay,
lock in, guys, not much time.
Just get as many colors as you can.
Hey, we got stairs!
We did good, we did good, we did good.
Nice.
Nice!
I took over a corner.
We got stairs!
Yeah!
Oh my god, let's go!
That was really good.
Oh, wow, nice, let's go.
Let's go, guys.
5600 blocks?
What the?
That's a lot of blocks.
Yeah, that's a lot of blockies.
I kind of like that version of the game a lot better.
Oh, go down.
What's this?
This is literally just trying to go down as fast as possible without dying.
You just want to go from block to block, there's power-ups.
You don't get points until you hit it, like...
Wait, without dying?
Yeah, without dying.
It's like dropper, but you just want to go from things.
Punching?
You can get kills, but they're worth literally no points.
They're worth like one point per kill or something.
The platforms are like power-ups and buffs that you can get.
Red is weapons, blue is items, and green is regen.
So go to green if you need healing, but just try to work your way down as fast as you can, essentially.
Yeah, but you don't get points unless you hit the platform thing.
So you have to make sure you hit it.
Whoa!
I died.
I missed.
He griefed mine, that's lovely.
Yeah, he griefed others.
That's the best part.
Like, why?
Somebody just...
Okay, I was being followed and punched.
That's chill, actually.
Is green not regen?
What's going on?
Green is regen.
I'm not really getting regen, okay.
Like...
I don't know.
I wasn't really getting regen on green, so I don't know.
I'm not really sure.
I'm confused.
Oh, it's really slow.
Oh man, that sucks for him.
Man, that's unfortunate.
What's blue?
I think you reach a checkpoint once you reach the glass area.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I died.
Oh, if you die, do you go...
It doesn't matter if you die, Anne.
Did you just go to your checkpoint?
Not necessarily, but...
Yeah, I just go to the last checkpoint.
No.
No!
I couldn't see it.
It was so hard to see.
Oh, there's laps.
Oh my god.
Yeah, there's laps.
If you get down one, you can go down again.
This pathing on the pink is hard, I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, I got, like, fucked up by the colors.
Fuck!
Wait, I think I might die for this, yeah.
I'm just getting killed, sorry.
No, you're fine.
Oh!
Fuck you!
Doki!
Kill him!
I killed him for it.
Oh my god, I can't tell where I am.
The pink is so hard.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
The pink one is hard.
Yeah, I couldn't tell.
It was incredibly difficult to see.
Do I die?
I literally almost got there, and then I, uh...
Okay?
Oh.
This game is, like, how am I supposed to make it to the bottom when that's a jump?
Yeah, be strong, that's what you get.
You don't.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I got one lap, that's hard, I don't know, that's hard.
This game is flawed because, like, you can't fall from a bridge to the bottom.
Esken!
Esken, look at you!
Let's go, Esken.
Let's go.
Oh, we got beaten.
We got beaten.
Um...
So this is parkour.
You just go back and forth.
And you need to do it in time.
Wait, what is this?
So you go back and forth doing parkour.
Each stage.
There's, like, a challenge side and a normal side.
I would do the...
Wait, which is the normal side?
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Oh, how do I get in?
Wait, is the orange on the challenge side?
It's the inventory.
Blue is normal side.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
And then you just do it back and forth?
No, no, so you keep running back and forth through the parkour.
Wait, I can't get out of it.
You can't go back.
No, you have to wait for the next one.
Oh!
Oh, wait, what?
I'm confused.
You just have to wait for the next map to spawn.
The side thing is...
Do the normal side if you're not confident in parkour.
Only do the hard side if you're, like, confident in doing parkour well.
Okay, I get it now, I get it.
Why is she doing over here?
What is this?
Okay.
Asuka, did you switch to our side?
Yeah.
Hana, are you on the normal side or challenge?
Challenge.
Challenge, challenge.
What?
No, I wasn't sure.
Oh, okay.
That was good handling.
You're cooking.
Yay!
Alright, keep it up, guys.
This is scary.
Asuka, if you have one life, maybe go to easy.
Okay, I'm still in full.
Other than that one.
Got you.
I fell.
I'm a bit confused for this one.
Oh, I fell too.
I'm risking it for the biscuit.
Okay, okay.
If you fall on the challenge side, you can also go back to normal as well.
I think you could do it.
Yay!
Honestly, that's not what you're comfortable with.
Yep.
Oh, I messed up.
I didn't realize there's a lower block.
Oh, that's so bad.
Okay, I fell.
Ant, should I go over?
Back to easy?
No, I have one life.
Maybe go back to normal.
No!
Ant, I'm dead.
I died.
Oh no.
I should've moved.
I didn't know you had to do it then.
Okay, I was a little confused earlier.
It's okay.
Yay!
Oh, I didn't know how many rounds there were left.
I thought that was the last one.
Because it said 3 out of 4.
I'm tripped.
Oh wait, it doesn't say how many there are.
Oh, here?
Oh, okay.
I thought it was cheatable parkour.
I feel like it's worth just staying on the challenge side.
What does challenge do?
It gives more points.
Wow!
Oh, I should've stopped sides.
Well, I'm gone.
I should've gone back.
This one's very hard.
I have one life.
It's worth going back, to be honest.
I messed up.
Speed doesn't matter, does it?
It gets faster every time.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm out.
I was like, the fuck?
The fuck?
What the fuck was I looking at?
Wait, there's only one guy alive left.
Yay!
Baller!
Oh, I want to try again.
You get two rounds of it, I think.
Really?
Yay!
Nice.
Donkey!
That's me!
Wait, Ant, do you get more points if you get first place?
If you completed the whole map, you get extra points.
But I don't think anybody did.
I think Red died before the map ended.
Is that Evbo?
Okay.
This is like a deathmatch.
Valorant deathmatch-esque.
Oh, I spawned right next to her.
It'll automatically reload your crossbow.
It auto-reloads your crossbow, so I guess you can just shoot.
Alright.
Yeah, and if you know where they're spawning, you can just camp it.
Okay, lock in, guys.
This is our game.
Woo!
Everybody's super close, though.
The points.
We killed each other!
Oh, we killed each other.
That's interesting.
Oh my god.
The AD.
Oh, Donkey, get him!
I can't!
Oh my god, I don't- I spawned- Are you serious?!
I don't know how to shoot anymore!
I'm washed!
No.
It automatically reloads, so don't stress, guys.
Oh my god, I'm washed.
I don't remember the- The charge- Oh my god, I don't remember!
The rain of fire!
I used to be a gamer at this.
He's hiding in the corner, crouching?
What?!
It's so over for me.
I literally just can't find anyone.
That's just my issue.
What?!
I'm feeding.
It's over for me.
I can't find anybody either.
Guys, my goal is one kill, guys.
There's no way- I did it!
I got one kill!
Okay.
I'm downloading the game.
We're doing good.
We're doing really good, by the way.
Thanks, guys.
What?!
Okay.
I'll learn.
I will learn.
No, I will not learn!
You guys, I got one kill.
It's okay, just cheat it.
No!
Why am I- One day, I will learn.
I keep trading.
Dr. Eggman, no!
What happened to me?
I used to be so good.
Last time.
Is it because I'm Tails?
Is it because- If I'm roleplaying as Tails, and that's what happened?
Oh my god.
Please, did I get that?
No, I couldn't even- Did I?
No, I didn't.
Guys, I think it's because I was Tails.
Not zero.
Kai's killstreak 8.
Oh, and us.
Hey, look, 6.
Not us, let's go.
There's like no point to put that all the way in.
This game doesn't even matter.
Literally, this game doesn't even matter.
Never go full Tails, guys.
I was one kill away from top 5.
Oh, nice!
Wow.
Never go full Tails.
We literally just have to be- We can be orange and pink in battle, for sure.
What else is there?
Spleef and- Spleef is sort of scary.
Maybe we should go with Spleef next.
Wait, is that all of Arcade?
My party?
Yeah.
So now we have Spleef Battle 8 minutes!
Why is it getting longer?
Wait, I'm going to see if there's Maria in this Minecraft skins.
Maria.
Margarita?
No, Maria.
Oh my god, there is!
Maria Robotnik!
We were cooking.
Wait.
I'm going to change skins real quick, guys.
In battle, we actually have to lock in.
No trolls.
I'm confident in battle.
I'm more scared about Blitz Hunt and Spleef, to be honest.
No, no, no.
I think this is the optimal lineup for us, for right now.
I agree, I agree.
I think we'll do good.
We'll cook in Blitz Hunt.
There's a reason Feinberg wanted to...
I think Purple wanted to play race last and battle now.
Because they're scared.
Doki, did you see the fuck you guy sent you?
Yeah.
Alright, I'm in.
Where is...
Dude, I think he's in shock.
He's in shock, yeah.
No, Shadow might be AFK.
Oh no, he's gonna miss Maria again.
Just look how...
And then she's just gonna die.
What?
Spoiler alert.
You don't know that?
No.
What?
They have guns?
It's Sonic the Hedgehog.
Yes!
Shadow fucking literally uses a gun.
He does?
Wait, really?
Yeah, in one of his first games.
He went to protect the president and then he has a gun.
It's true!
The president called him...
The president called Shadow the Hedgehog and he has a gun.
Dude, I feel like you're just making up shit.
No, it's true!
That's like the one Shadow game I wish they reboot.
They remaster.
It's his weapon of choice.
A gun?
Yeah!
Shadow gun.
It's a literal game on the PS2.
It's on the PS2.
Oh my god, he does have a gun.
Yeah, and then he talks with the president.
Why did Sega give Shadow a gun?
He uses a SIG SG551.
It has a 30 round capacity.
I wish they remastered Shadow.
That game.
That is the best Sonic game they've ever made.
Oh my god, the sun's about to go down.
Oh, the sun's already down.
They gave him the gun?
They gave him a gun in the new Sonic movie?
Oh my god, say less.
Wait, when is the new Sonic movie coming out, guys?
I think December.
Oh, no fun.
Wait, no, today is December.
Wait, oh my god, it's December.
Oh, it's 20th.
Oh my god, it's gonna come out on the 20th.
Oh my god, early Christmas gift to me.
Yeah, and then they made the new expansion chat, but like, it's not the same.
You don't have a gun in that game.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he's not.
I can't believe Shadow is AFK.
How could he do this to us?
Gumi, how do you not know Sonic lore?
And you're being a poser.
Because I never played any Sonic, man.
You're a fucking poser!
You're the one that told me to put on the Amy skin, you scumbag!
You're a poser!
I think Gumi might need to be voted off the team for that.
Oh my god.
Yeah, vote...
You're voted off the island.
You are a fuck you guy.
I knew you were a fuck you guy.
Oh my god.
You're the one that told me to be Amy, you scumbag!
I'm one of those people that are like, oh yeah, you know Sonic and Hedgehog?
Give me like...
Name me five Sonic characters right now.
That's right.
Oh god.
I can't believe...
I'm gonna go pee and then maybe he'll wake me up.
You know what?
I might drink a coffee.
You're gonna drink a coffee?
Wait, SK, do you know Sonic lore?
No, I don't know any.
Wait, you don't even play Sonic?
And you're a Sonic the Hedgehog?
It's Sonic skin.
Oh my god.
I used to play the...
There was like a Sega Mario Kart game.
Where you could be Sonic.
It was so fun.
You gotta play Sonic now.
If you're gonna be Sonic the Hedgehog, you gotta play Sonic.
I can't be a fraud.
Yeah, you can't be a fraud.
You're not a real gamer unless you play Sonic.
I was like trying to think of cool Sonic lines to say for real.
You didn't even say like, you're too slow.
You didn't even say that.
Wait a minute, does SK know anything about Sonic?
I'm an imposter.
Queen never cry.
Is there a queen number cry skin?
I'm pretty sure there is, but like, how would you make that a skin though?
Dude, the fuck ass baby.
That's L.
Guys, no, I was not a Sonic girl.
I learned more.
I just like to read Wikipedias.
Heimerdinger Minecraft skin.
Dude.
My favorite Sonic comic is the Knuckles Nipple comic.
What?
Wait, do you not know that comic?
Oh wait, you don't know Sonic lore.
That guy ended up becoming an official artist for Sonic the Hedgehog.
That is crazy.
I think we should vote for Hunt.
Or Spleef.
Where's Battle?
Oh, there's Battle.
Okay.
No, we have to do like, Spleef or something.
We cannot do Battle.
Okay, I'm gonna grab somebody.
Yeah, grab someone and bring them to Spleef.
Oh, you can see what the games are by looking above.
There's a sign that says it.
How do I grab somebody?
Get over here.
You're coming here with me.
Everybody get in the corner for Spleef.
I got him.
I got somebody.
Oh wait, we're gonna, yeah, we get Spleef.
My savior.
Yeah, we got it.
We got Spleef.
Yeah.
Not my captain.
Alright.
Hunt, any suggestions?
I would do your best to try and stay together-ish if you can.
Islanding is fine, but the border will shove you in, so don't cut your way off to the middle.
But just from Snowballs in the beginning, try and stay alive together.
Alright.
Can I hit people with the Snowballs?
Yes, you can hit people, or you can hit blocks with Snowballs, and it'll break them.
There's one round of TNT Spleef where you'll get a bow, and if you shoot the ground, and there's like, if you shoot the ground, it'll blow up like a 3x3 area.
Awesome.
I think the highest layer that you can be on before it starts to decay, I think the third layer, everything decays together, so if you can stay on that layer, it's really good because you get the high ground.
Let's be friends, guys.
What do you mean by that, Ant?
So like, the first two layers will decay by themselves, but when you get to the third layer, the third, fourth, and fifth layer all decay together.
Oh yeah.
So the third layer is like the highest layer you can be on, which is good if you can stay there, but you can also farm kills on the bottom, except to...
you know.
That one's better to be higher.
Try not to, uh...
make any enemies, guys.
Do I know you?
Alright, lock in, lock in, lock in.
I have an enemy.
It's Shadow the Hedgehog.
True.
Let's find Shadow the Hedgehog and put an end to him.
No!
Not Shadow!
He's already gone through so much!
Oh my god, it's so laggy.
Okay, Hannah, just farm symbols on us.
The first layer does not matter that much.
Maybe Shadow won't...
Maybe Shadow won't try to kill me when he sees me.
Serious?
Oh my god.
Well, I will just dedicate my game to ruining your game.
Small ant, small ant, why?
Whoops.
Oh no.
You can break up, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I broke up, but...
You actually thought you could do something.
I sleeped, CaptainSparklez.
Eleven-year-old me is freaking out.
How dare you not become friends!
These people are so evil!
I told you, nobody wants to be friends!
I try to be friends!
The live-shoot person!
I'm killing LineJack.
Don't... I mean...
I will dedicate the rest of my game to trolling you.
Why can't we be friends?
What?
How are you still alive?
Why can't we be friends?
No full auto in the building!
I got that reference.
That was so obscure.
Yes!
But we can try and just play high ground anyways.
Oh, handsome fellow on you, hold up.
Whoa!
He doesn't want the smoke.
I don't have any smoke.
Yeah, let's just try and stay here.
No one's really here.
There's some people above us, so...
Oh my god, he wants to fight me, but I just want to be friends.
Eventually we're going to have to go down to the third layer and fight for this.
Okay.
I'm scared now.
Awkward.
That's a little awkward.
What's this?
Okay, I died.
I feel like I got targeted by everybody.
I usually do, though.
It's okay, I made some friends.
Goomy, we got...
Uh-oh.
I'm on the last layer already.
Whoa!
Me too.
You're in a good spot.
No!
I got creeped!
Oh my god!
I got creeped so hard.
It's okay, I made friends last.
I lived as long as I could.
Hey, what's going on here?
What the?
Five up.
Five up is above you.
Where?
Five up.
Nice, stay there.
He's coming over!
Why would he kill himself for that?
Oh my god.
I placed seventh!
Yay!
Let's go!
This game is so troll.
I would say, Hanna, just don't... maybe just don't fight people as much then.
If people run at you, just try and...
Let's stand in the same area.
Okay.
Where are you?
I don't see you.
I see SK, though.
You're literally running the wrong way.
Oh, I see you, I see you, I see you.
Oh my god.
Okay, SK, come here, SK.
Oh, okay, I'm coming.
Hello.
Oh, we're gonna make our own...
Oh, I like it.
Oh my god, it's like lagging here.
No, shut up's here.
Hi.
Eggman.
Hey.
Someone dug out from under me.
I'm below now.
Yeah, if you die, why don't you die?
That's good revenge.
Whoa.
Okay, I just got griefed again.
I'm just trying to stand still.
What if we go to the bottom layer and dig everything out?
What if I die because of that?
No, he doesn't want to be friends.
Why can't we be friends?
Yeah, friendship is so cool, guys.
Dude, I'm sensing there's some fuck you guys near me.
There's always fuck you guys.
Okay, Doki, this is the king.
I did not make the jump.
That's fine.
I like being down here.
Wait, wait, what?
I looked up for one second and I got hit.
I got hit at the bottom.
That's actually crazy.
How is Wall-E still up there?
I agree, Ty.
Don't hurt me, I'm just a little guy.
I would bet $1,000 five upset Targehanna.
To his team.
Alright, fuck you, I guess, too.
I think we just try and hold over here.
We're going to have to find a spot down here.
Everybody wants to kill.
And it makes me sad.
Shane, why?
Everyone has murder in their eyes.
The top was so free.
The top people were so nice.
Three layers at once.
Guys, people at the top were so nice.
The bottom was wild animals.
Wild animals at the bottom.
I made more friends at the top.
Oh my god, Antfrost, be careful.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Nice.
It's close, though.
Yeah, nice work.
Message Fire Breath Man.
Watch your back.
Oh my god.
The people at the bottom are savages.
They're savages.
People at the top were so nice.
I was friends with people at the top.
Okay, so this one, SK.
You have a bow, and you shoot the ground.
You can shoot people, but if you shoot the ground, it'll break a 3x3.
The crossbow that you have, you can rocket jump with.
So if you shoot it in the ground under you, it'll just boost you up, and you can go up layers with it.
Okay, where are you?
Honestly, just use the crossbow off the rip.
Don't go on the outer layers.
Stay towards the middle, because it's safer there.
Use the crossbow off the rip, and just try it to see how it feels.
You can also use the crossbow if you want.
As a way to rocket jump and kill people.
Like if you're on somebody.
That's awesome.
You can shoot people with the bows, too.
I don't know if I can punch or not.
Joe Bart, please.
Oh, shit!
On you is a pink player.
No, I couldn't get that.
Oh, I almost got the shadow.
No!
That shadow!
Generally, staying on the top is pretty good.
It is.
Staying on the top is good.
I would go in more.
Staying on the outer layers here is scary.
Because you can get shot off the map easier.
True.
And grief 5 up.
Oh, no.
Goomy.
Goomy!
Oh.
No.
Oh, my God.
No, fuck.
Oh, I don't know where the...
Oh, God.
Goomy.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
I got dropped at the bottom.
No!
What?
I got hit on the side.
Oh, you're on the top.
But they're gonna come back up.
Behind you, Ant.
Oh.
Where were you guys?
Oh, nice.
Guys, I was in the first one out.
Look at this.
Oh, my God.
I'm alive for now, but...
Alright, SK, we're in a good spot.
But behind you.
Oh, never mind.
They fell.
Behind you.
Oh.
Oh, my.
Guys, you guys... Whoa!
You guys are gaming!
Oh, my God.
There's so many aimers here.
Oh, God!
Oh, no.
Can purple, like, stop?
Nope.
He's coming back.
I see him.
I died.
Oh, it's you, Ant.
You got this.
Oh, you're still alive.
You're so healthy.
No!
That was so fucked!
That was so fucked.
Nice work.
Yeah, that was really good.
We got third this round.
It's pretty good.
Whoa, fourth is really good.
We did better.
Look, we didn't do better than pink, purple, and orange.
And we didn't do better than purple and orange, but we cleared pink by, like, a mile.
Like, we did really good.
I'm, like, the mascot.
I'm here to roleplay.
There's tears.
Don't worry.
I'm just...
I'm the roleplayer.
Um...
What?
We just got battle last, right?
Like, we just got battle last single.
We have to.
But will we get battle last, though?
Um...
Maybe not.
What's our last two games?
Blitz hunt and battle.
What's blitz hunt again?
That's the hide and seek game.
Oh, shit.
That one.
Okay.
Thank you for the raid!
I didn't see who raided.
Thank you so much.
I'm doing a Minecraft block wars.
I usually don't stream on Twitch, but this is a Twitch Rivals for charity.
I'm the mascot because I'm not doing so well individually.
You guys are so nice.
Oh, Leina, thank you for the raid.
I really appreciate it.
Guys, it's okay.
I'm here for roleplay RP.
This is my RP session.
Yeah, we like... Okay, and...
So, it's not capturing points anymore?
Or... No, it is.
You have to, like, go on...
There are the capture points, which are really good for points.
And then there's also the PvP.
You just have to walk on it.
We're going to go for a point no matter what.
We're never going to, like, not take a point because someone else is there.
Because we're probably better than all the other teams.
Do you think that we should use the damages from the totem kit, like, when we're sword fighting?
Or when we're bow fighting?
When we're sword fighting.
We should place it on the point.
We place it on the actual point.
Okay.
I mean, that's what I did, and it worked really well.
Yeah.
I mean, I think, like, what if we're in a situation where we're having a bow fight over the point, though?
Like, if they're, like, shooting at us a lot and we can't really sword fight them.
Then we should be standing on the point bowing them.
Like, so then we get the point.
Well, I mean, if you're on archer, like, the damage totem does, like, boost your bow damage a lot.
I don't play archer.
You don't play archer?
I've never played archer.
I mean, it's...
I think the best kits are archer and summoner because I think scout or whatever it is has chainmail, which is really bad armor.
Okay.
If you don't want to play archer, I don't mind playing archer, but...
What's summoner?
Summoner... I don't know if it's, like, a crossbow or what it is, or snowball and egg, but you can spawn mobs, and they just, like, do damage, essentially.
Which one has the TNT?
I don't remember what it's called.
Like the creeper one?
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't think it's very good.
Guys, so in battle, we're going to go to the first point.
Realistically, we should all be, like, standing on it, capturing the point, and that's when SK, if you want to go that, like, OP kit where it has, like, the villager totems, you can place, like, the healing one on us, and then when they start running at us,
like, place the the damage one.
And then you have really OP armor, too, because all of the...
Yeah, all the healer classes get diamond armor for no reason.
Yeah, so we're gonna run three healer classes regardless.
It's hard to die.
Yeah.
Isn't your health, like, decays down?
You lose all your items?
I think we go hunt.
I don't think we're gonna get it, but we might as well try.
We have to.
We have to go blitz hunt.
It's unlikely we're gonna get hunt, unless we get...
Oh my god, there's a TNT in pink, in the hunt area.
I can do a TNT.
Wait, they're putting TNT on us!
We lost three people, that's unlucky.
I killed people, too, though.
Nice, Hannah.
Wait, we have a revival title!
It's okay, I can live forever.
I think people are booting...
Oh, no, the cat's going forward.
Yeah, I think it's gonna be battle.
That's a lot of people in battle, guys.
Like, they don't understand that none of them are going to be able to come back.
Because blitz hunt has such a small point differential, nobody's going to be able to come back.
Okay, gg.
Fighters versus phantoms at the end.
I don't understand.
We just have to have a generational battle.
Like, I'm sorry.
They just don't understand.
It's fine, it's fine.
We'll cook this game.
Ah, Maria.
Oh, that's new!
At the very very end, that like white place, that's the only place that you can survive.
Like, at the final final border.
What was I before?
Gumi, what did I play last time?
You played a healer.
I know, but which one?
Was I the fairy?
Yeah, fairy.
You regen us whenever you're near us, you just give us regen like always.
Yeah.
No, I think Giga was fairy.
I think I was the other one with the potions.
Okay, so we're gonna have to like stand on these, and SK, that's where you'll place the healing, and then when they when we're fighting them on the point, also place that.
So, the totems are one-shots, so if they're like shooting at us, SK, try and put it in a way where it's like on us, but like behind most of us.
No, they're not one-shot.
You get them back.
No, no, no, I mean like if they shoot the totem it dies, and it'll go on cooldown.
It's a breakable one-shot, is what I'm saying.
Yeah, where would I put it on that point?
There's nowhere good.
Just like behind us.
Honestly, just put it behind us.
We're never capturing this.
Like on us, but in the back so that we don't get for all the kits.
So I want it to be the totem.
Yeah.
Uh...
I think I liked summoner last time.
I was the one with the potion.
I was gonna run summoner if that's okay with me.
Who was the...
Or did you want it?
Okay.
Who was the potion healer?
It's probably the last one.
Medic, I think it's medic.
Yeah, I like medic.
Okay, um...
So we, so do we have one person on totem, fairy, and medic?
I think we should.
SK, can you go totem?
Oh, summoner gets the TNT chickens.
Mac, absorption, insta health.
I think you should go archer.
Archer is like, you get full iron, you get a bow, and you get a stone sword.
Okay, fine.
You don't get arrows back, do you?
You do, you get them over time.
Okay, fine, fine, fine.
And every two or three shots you hit, you get a damage arrow.
Which is a ton of damage.
Insta health, absorption.
Who do I throw absorption at?
Um, we're about to fight and you throw absorption on us.
Oh, Gumi, where are you going?
Uh, I was told we were running three supports.
I mean, honestly, like, the thing is, the diamond armor alone makes it broken, but the other classes are just bad.
Like, if you play scout or assassin, you just instant die because it's leather and chainmail.
Like, you just can't live on those kits.
Um, I think honestly, Gumi, you can sort of, like, yeah, I think you can sort of play on the frontlines with us, like, just critting people out.
Because you have full diamond, you have regen for all of us.
Like, I think if we get a damage totem, you'd, like, two or three shot people with crits if it's active on you.
Okay, I guess it looks like everyone else is doing your strategy.
They learned from you.
Yeah.
I mean, it's just good, but I think we'll do it better, so it's fine.
Whoa!
Should I offhand the bow?
Where am I?
Hannah, this is that one map with, like, all this snow and airy like this.
Just follow me and Hannah.
I think we go straight and go to the side here.
I think we go out the window here, I think.
Alright, cool.
Right?
And then we go out here.
Come up here, come up here.
Right here, right here.
Blue's coming.
Jump on this point.
I'll bow.
Place the healing on us.
I did.
Healing totem in the back, healing totem in the back.
We have it.
Once we have the point, we can leave.
Yeah, just... we're almost... we got it, we got it.
Let's leave, let's leave.
Go to the middle.
Yeah, let's just go middle.
Look out, there's void, there's void.
Watch out for the void.
Hold this, hold this.
After this, guys... oh, we have to jump back, Hannah.
Oh, that's weird.
Okay.
This is void, we have to jump back.
You can blue and leave.
I don't have damage.
Shoot them from the damage, Hannah.
We have the point, guys, we need to go.
Come here, come here, jump to me.
Whoa, that's fine, I'm okay.
Let's hold the top right.
Let's go up here, let's go up and go back, Hannah.
Are you sure we just hold mid?
Yeah, mid.
Actually, this is really good.
Look at this bridge right here.
This is a fight, though.
Do you want to third party, Hannah?
Yeah, let's see if we can get a clean on somebody here.
Wait, let's chill for a second.
Whoa, there's a zone.
Come back, come back.
Oh my god.
We have a spot right here, I don't hate this.
Let's go right here, this is perfect.
I'm going to shoot their...
It's so chill up here.
We're not fighting, there's a lot of fights going on.
Hey, guys.
Wait, you change your skin back to me?
I don't know.
We have to help the opposer.
Hannah, keep shooting, keep shooting.
Hide, hide.
Hide behind that wall, hide behind that wall.
Oh, they broke it.
I'll try and break theirs.
I broke it.
I have no arrows, currently.
We have to go ahead and stay... you'll regen, you'll regen, you'll regen.
Okay, so we're going to fall right...
and we're going to stay top, we're going to stay on the top.
Alright, cool.
I have instant heals if you guys... whoever needs it.
Keep shooting fruit if you can, Hannah.
I have no arrows.
It's just like Fortnite.
Oh my god.
I'm chilling.
We do need kills.
We could kill...
actually.
Let's wait for pink to fight purple and then let's do something, maybe.
I think we should go down, I think we should...
I think we should go down a little bit, yeah.
Oh, we're smoked, they smoked us.
There's like people over on...
We're hidden right now.
Purple's under us, purple's under us.
Don't engage, don't engage.
Purple's down two players, purple's down two players.
They're fighting pink right now.
Okay, let's run at pink.
Let's just run at pink and start critting them out.
Oh my god, what happens to my sword?
Fineberg is low.
Alright guys, let's try and stay together a little bit.
You're like alone at mid.
Shane's low, Shane's low, Shane's on six.
Shane's low, Shane's low, Shane's low.
Stay together, stay together, stay together.
Yay!
Oh, careful.
Come middle, come middle.
Okay.
Shoot blue, Hannah, shoot blue.
I'm trying to get a kill.
I'm sorry, I don't want a kill still, but...
I want to confirm that.
Hold middle and try to hit them in the void.
If possible.
We got orange.
No, no, we're fine, we're good.
Look blue, look blue, blue's the big team.
Like, get little crits if you can.
Okay, Michael, make sure...
He's dead, he's dead, he's dead.
Okay, look at that two blue.
Yeah, get little crits on them like that.
Get shooting, get shooting, get shooting.
I'm getting shot.
Final, final, final fight.
It's Igben!
Nice!
Let's go!
Yay!
Holy shit.
Generational battle, generational battle.
We played that perfectly.
Generational.
I killed Igben.
I feel like I wasn't doing that much.
I mean, the arrows do a lot of damage.
I think it's just so much healing that it's hard, but you're farming damage points.
There's damage points in this, Hannah.
You're getting a million points from shooting people off.
Okay, so we're going to do the exact same thing.
Yeah.
Blue is really slow to get to the point.
The next team might be a little faster to try and contest this.
I don't know.
Are those multiplied?
The points already?
I don't know.
I feel like they are already.
I think they are.
Did I kill Everomi?
No, nothing.
Do you want to hang out?
Yeah, yeah.
Yay!
I was critting someone out and did nothing.
I'm telling you, the healing classes, it's so hard to kill them.
They just take so much.
Especially because if you have a fairy, you get permanent regen as well.
It's just so ridiculous.
Yeah.
Okay, so let's do the same exact thing.
Take the headshot shortcut.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Do I use it right away?
The splash absorption?
If people are fighting us, you can.
They're fighting us to try and...
They're going on the point.
Let's just go as fast as we can.
After this, we'll go to the middle.
I'll just shoot at them to make them go away.
Alright, they're going away.
After this, we're going to pulse the middle, okay?
Alright.
30 left.
Okay, I'll just shoot at them.
Go middle, go middle, go middle.
Go middle, go middle.
Look out for the void.
Be careful of the void again.
You have to go around the side here like this and then go on.
Alright.
I'll look around.
Up there on the bridge.
Once we have all the points, I think we go back where we came from.
I think we go back this way, guys.
Yeah, we go back where we came from.
Wait, everyone leave, everyone leave.
They're chasing.
Everyone come this way.
Purple is chasing.
Purple is chasing blue right now.
Purple is chasing blue.
Should we go behind purple, Hannah, or should we play safe?
No, wait.
I think we go back up there and just play our lives.
Let's go high ground again.
High ground is OP.
There's one person...
Wait, never mind.
Never mind, I'm an idiot.
I'm an idiot.
Look, there's a massive fight over there by yellow and red.
I don't know if we want to third party that or not, though.
Blue is behind us.
There's purple behind us.
I think we have our spot and we should just play.
Purple is playing for kills right now.
Yeah, we have a good spot.
We have a good spot.
Let's just take our spot.
And I'll shoot a green.
Purple is just full playing for kills right now.
I don't think anybody can get behind us.
I think we're chill over here right now.
Maybe we can just spam.
Just spam like crazy.
There's purple to our left.
Careful.
Oh, pink.
Purple is annoying me.
Don't worry, I got heals.
There's green to our right.
Hannah, you're doing a lot of damage.
Your pink is under us right now.
Don't worry about pink.
I'm not concerned.
Hannah, you have damage boost if you move back a little bit.
Orange is shooting us.
I need a clear shot to orange.
Hannah, big fight to our side.
No, it's down under on the bottom.
Can you see that?
I don't know if it's worth it or not.
They're not fighting like that.
Red is under us.
Can I have a clear shot?
I'm going to kill Feinberg.
I'm chilling.
Taboo is totally under us at 9 HP.
Taboo is 9 HP under us right now.
No, not worth it.
We have the corner.
I'm dropping with you.
I think we have to.
Three of us stay up here.
I'm chilling.
I think just keep spamming pink.
We need to do better than pink.
Spam them with our abilities first.
Captain Sparkle is a solo.
You might want to kill him.
Don't go too far.
I'm coming in.
Let's sit up here.
I'm so chill up here.
I'm a chill guy.
We're going to get targeted.
Just chill.
I'm a chill guy.
How about pink is all of red?
Just a chill guy.
Is someone fighting us?
No, a spider.
I think we have to go down.
Let's go down.
Kill these spiders.
I don't know if we go for middle again.
We get rushed by everything.
We stay here.
Spam with your bow.
He absorbed us again.
I just threw it.
Do you have the healing totem?
Yeah, I have both.
We should go mid and damage.
Damage and start shooting.
Go.
Boom.
Purple,
if you can.
Shadow, no shadow.
This is a lot of people.
No, she didn't get me.
We did good.
I wasn't getting any kills there.
We have a lead by 500 points.
Now we are cooking.
We are going to do the same thing.
I was at one heart.
It is hard.
If we are the first team to go there, it is good.
The purple just chilled.
I saw purple chill.
Maybe we just rush purple in that situation.
Because the other two teams were fighting on the other side.
Yeah, I think you are right.
This is the OWL.
When you are at the bottom at mid, you can crit them upwards.
You can look at them up when they are on that platform and just crit them out.
They can't really do that to you.
Yeah, because they have a high ground advantage.
That is good.
I am lucky that orange ran into us.
And every other team did too.
I forgot to choose my kit.
You have 10 seconds.
I didn't realize the overtime thing.
I still had our healing totem.
That was probably a big difference.
I didn't use it.
I think it disappears in overtime.
I am not sure.
If it is on the ground, it might disappear.
It does.
I think we were half HP when it went to OT.
If I used it before, we would be full.
We got it.
Let's speedrun to our spot.
Is this purple?
Don't worry.
Just go.
Place them.
Everyone come close together.
I put absorption just in case.
They broke it.
Wait for the point.
They are pretty low.
We got it.
They are leaving.
Nice.
Good work.
Should we push?
Let's go middle.
I used all my resources.
Yellow is on it.
Purple is going for it.
Yellow is on it right now.
Let them have it.
Yellow is low.
Do we want to fight more?
We are winning.
I used up all my resources for that.
It was worth it.
That was good.
Let's do the same.
We are winning right now.
We don't need to throw that away.
We can risk it for the biscuit.
Behind us.
Lime only has two.
Let's kill them.
Kill this person in the border.
I didn't get it.
Let's stay up.
I think we should stay up.
If we see a full team fight going on with red and yellow, maybe we can push that.
Yellow is winning.
There are a bunch of minions.
There is a summoner.
Oh yeah.
I'm trying to shoot them.
There is a lime hiding under the bridge.
There is a red hiding under us.
We can shoot him.
We should go down to Hannah.
I think she will be fine.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to fall.
There is a lot of people below.
They can come to the water here.
Ant, please come here.
Pink is not going to do anything to us.
They are going to chill.
I feel like we can just kill pink.
Maybe I'm wrong.
There is yellow hiding.
Purple is a team of three.
I think we can't go under them.
I think we should mess with them.
They are shooting purple.
There is two yellows there.
Yellow is coming to us.
Yellow wants to come to us.
They are going to have to come down.
Kill the mobs.
Purple is at five.
We should push.
Be careful.
Don't get too aggressive.
We are going to get killed.
Let's kill purple.
Oh my god.
I'm not with you guys.
Guys, no.
I think we got too aggressive on purple.
All of orange is on you.
They are targeting us.
You can go middle.
They are all on us.
Go middle.
One blue on you.
You can go middle.
Do you have any heals?
I'm waiting for heals now.
I'm waiting for two.
You guys are fine.
Just kill the mobs.
Kill the mobs.
Get ready.
On you, green player.
On hannah.
I'm trying to keep her alive.
Good kill.
Yellow on you.
They went back.
Honestly, just play for...
I don't even know.
Orange is split.
I have heals in two or three, I think.
They are going to mosh.
They are going to mosh soon.
Help hannah.
Help hannah on orange.
Fruits on you.
You got yours.
Oh my god.
The mosh pit.
You got yours.
Honestly, I'm fine.
Look at the gap.
Holy shit.
We are moshing.
We just gapped by a thousand.
Holy shit.
That was really good.
That was incredible.
I told you.
You didn't believe me.
Let's go.
I got first.
I'm taking a screenshot.
Oh, I'm third.
Let's go.
Give me third.
Oh my god.
I think I'm going to go that river.
That's my wife.
You can literally be Sonic's wife.
Oh my god.
Blitzhunt is going to be hard, but we can do it.
We have to have a historic Blitzhunt.
We have to lock into Blitzhunt.
We closed that gap really, really, really well.
Let's go.
You have to find a really good hidey spot.
Wait, we shouldn't stick together.
Oh my god, wait, wait.
I'm going to get camouflage skin.
Oh, you're so right.
Hurry, find a dirt block.
Oh my god, you're right.
Give me a sec.
I have two minutes.
I'll be right back.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you're so right.
Wait, what's a good dirt block?
Oh, I found a really good one.
She said, what's a good dirt block?
We're metagaming, boys.
And before, like, this is the worst I've ever done in Blitz.
I used to have a skin.
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
Do people ever, like, go into rooms together?
Like, as a team?
As a duo?
Um, you can.
If you know of a good spot, like, you see a room and it's a really good spot, you can go to play together.
Yeah, there's some really crazy spots.
Oh, no, I mean hunting.
Oh, yeah, no, you can definitely do that.
I mean, I think it's, like, not bad at all.
Especially if, like, people are...
Like, if I'm going on a roof to get people off of it, who's under and just killing people, I think it works fine.
Um, I don't think it's good to recheck middle.
A lot of people like to go to middle.
They'll never know.
Wait, how did you find a full dirt?
Okay, well, I didn't find a dirt.
I can just stand like this.
And it's like a part of the structure.
I have hair.
Wait, why are you a penguin?
I just thought I would be really cool.
Wait, God, there's a snow area.
There's a snow area.
You should be a penguin right in.
Wait, Doki, what if it's Christmas themed and there's snow instead of dirt?
Oh, that's true!
It's so fun!
Oh my God, do we look for it?
We don't have time!
It's so fun!
They heard us.
Oh, we'll find out.
That was a generational battle.
Two people are gonna like...
This is a pro lobby, so they're gonna be F5ing it, aren't they?
Probably.
You can make your F5 something easier to click.
No, but like...
That means I can't do the spots I like, cause they'll see it.
I see what you mean.
Wait, F5?
They'll have me in third person, so they'll see it's easier to find people.
They'll know.
There's a misplaced block.
Oh, we're finding everything.
Are we hunting?
Honestly, this is fine, because people are gonna be less practiced and less warmed up.
They're not gonna move as much.
Guys, you run around and you just sprint...
Sorry, what am I even trying to say?
You can spam click them.
Are they disguised as blocks?
No, no.
They're not like us.
Hunters have a sonar to show the amount of hiders nearby.
Yeah, but it's a long cooldown, so like...
So, there are some rooms that are easier to find people than others, but people are moving around at all times, and so it's in a circle around the center.
Does that make sense?
We should all go in different directions.
It's one room in the middle, and then every room around it is a giant loop you can do.
Yeah, we should all go different directions.
It is not a bad idea to check middle again.
There's some places you can hide at middle later on.
The sonar you get will tell you...
I think it's roughly 10-20 blocks.
I'm going east.
I'm going left.
People don't know what direction you're going, because they'll decide based on who goes where.
Does that make sense?
Like, if someone's good...
Do you know what I mean?
I'm going the other way.
Try hard, Dirt Master!
We thought it was funny!
We just thought it was funny!
I want to win for charity.
I want to be the one to donate to Minecraft charity.
I want it to be us.
I'm the mascot.
I call west.
Okay, I'm gonna go north, actually.
Doki, you should go west with me.
No, we gotta split it up.
There's only four.
Wait, but who's gonna go north?
I'm going north.
Okay, west.
It says I'll go east, don't worry.
Yeah, I'll go north.
Sorry, I was trying to troll them and make it look like I wasn't going north.
Just check corners.
I would say people will try to loop around things.
Make sure to remember to check and watch for that or try to loop around yourself a couple times.
Alright, cool.
I don't know if anyone's gonna hide in spawn off.
No, they're not.
No one's hiding in spawn off rip, don't worry.
Unless...
Oh, it's the city thing.
Interesting.
Oh.
Okay.
Is there anyone here?
No players here.
They won't know I'm a dirt block.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, I see them.
They're parkouring.
They know I can't parkour.
Why did you come the same way as me?
We're supposed to split up.
Zero players in here.
How do they keep disappearing?
Oh my god, they're so good.
Maybe I shouldn't chase the minecrafters.
I'm not doing well.
Nobody in middle right now that I can see.
I think I'm in these corner spots.
Yeah, I'm not doing well.
Oh, hey.
I saw someone here.
There's someone in this room.
I just saw someone, but I don't know where they went.
You just move on.
There's only three mid.
There's three people here.
Oh, okay.
Doctor!
Oh wait, that's not Dr. Eggman.
That's fine.
He can live.
I just did so bad.
I got four.
It's okay.
I got two.
Doki, look for the dirt.
Oh, look for dirt.
We gotta look for dirt.
No, there is.
I don't like any of these.
This lava room is not a cook.
You can go to the corner, but I would not sit in the lava room.
Okay, but what if I'm here?
Oh, this room looks abysmal.
This is a bad room.
Wait, this room is horrible.
Do we have to shift to hide our names or no?
No.
I might be dead off rip.
I feel like I'm dead off rip.
I'm a dirt block in a fucking ice area.
I'm a dirt block on the roof.
No, why did that person fall?
Oh my god.
I thought they were on me.
How do you get up to where 5-Up is?
I'm so confused.
The water tower, right?
No.
Oh, do you have to go to the mushroom?
Can you spec me?
Oh.
Yeah, I can't get you.
Hold on.
Oh, this is a hard room to run in, but I think you'll be fine.
Somebody's coming in now.
They're leaving.
It's one of the weaker players.
You're fine.
Wait, they can hear heartbeats now?
They're on the bottom right now, Hannah.
They didn't see you.
You can go back to the spot if you want.
I feel like this spot isn't horrible.
No, it's pretty good.
Um...
I would say play...
Is there a jump pad across to you?
They can jump pad to you, so I'll tell you if somebody's going up to you, I guess.
No, you're fine.
Try jump pad away.
Oh, you could.
Oh my god, this is so scary.
It is.
Literally, all of you are going to live if you have eight seconds.
I'm brown and I'm blended in the room.
We need this.
This is really good.
It's really good.
Awesome.
That was amazing.
Good round.
Hannah, this paint room is really good.
I need brown.
I need a blend in.
Okay, okay.
I'll go back into it.
I'll come back.
I need a deep brown.
Amazing, amazing.
Sorry I'm taking this so serious.
I just want to do it well.
I'm just okay.
That was a great round.
That was an amazing round for us.
Oh, it's this goofy sand map where they took away my skip.
I don't know.
Guys, I might...
I might be dead.
Guys.
I'm dead.
I think I'm dead.
No, no, no, no.
No, guys, guys, guys.
I have green on my head.
I didn't have the full dirt skin.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Try to find a spot where you're just hidden.
And we'll be fine.
Okay, can this person next to me stop trolling?
Oh my god.
Okay, sorry.
It's gonna keep trolling.
Goodbye, world.
There's four of us in this corner.
Purple was found by Feinberg first.
See you on the other side.
I won't be caught so I don't have to feel stressed anymore.
Oh, why is there so so much?
I want you to survive.
Take me out of my misery.
This paint room isn't that bad.
I'm aging 20 years.
Goodbye.
Uh, who's that?
I'm in the paint room.
This is actually not even a bad spot, I think.
This actually might be the most Mickey spot I've ever seen but it might work.
I hate this.
Come on, guys.
Stay alive.
You got this.
Get me out of here.
Thank you so much.
I'm one with nature.
Get me out of here.
Get me out!
SK, look at me.
SK, I have not moved from this spot once.
How do I find you?
I'm alive.
We're doing so good.
Oh my god.
SK died.
What do you mean?
We all lived.
SK eliminated.
That's fucked.
Sometimes you're going to die.
It's not your fault.
This room looks kind of weird, Ant.
I don't know about this room.
The sand room is trolled.
You're not going to the sand room.
It's the tree room.
This tree room is OP as hell.
I think I fucked up.
Oh no.
I found my spot.
The generational spot.
I don't have a spot.
Me too.
Sorry, I can't tell you the direction.
Tree room in one of the corners.
Goodbye.
Please remember me.
This is such a bad spot to be in.
It's over.
But I'll grab us two points just in case.
Wait, chat, do I have to go somewhere else?
Or is this the spot?
Okay, guys, but I can grab us two points.
You're safe, you're safe, but don't come here.
You're so fucking mean.
Who's inside of you?
If they're coming, I'm going to leave them away, okay?
Okay, and then I'm totally blending in.
If anybody will blend in, it's definitely me.
Dude, I'm literally in an ice area.
I'm against grey.
No.
Oh my god, if I do block wars again, I want all our skins to be black colors.
Sand, rock, dirt.
Sand, rock, dirt, coal.
They don't know my head.
They can't read my mind.
That's the thing.
I find the most stupid spots and it works.
My mind is an enigma.
Wait, I don't see any...
I don't see trees.
How do I do?
I don't see any amazing rooms.
I would check the corners.
That corner is lava.
The right.
This is my favorite.
This room is horrible.
Oh my god.
It's not bad for me.
The other corner, it's a village room.
A village room is scary.
I think we commit to this one.
This room is horrible.
Wait, why are we all here?
Why are we all here?
We all have faith in this room.
I am going to leave if I have to.
Just so you guys know.
Honestly, somebody is coming in.
We are fine.
I think this room is not bad.
You can look through the bottom.
You can play around the top.
It's hard to like...
The Among Us needs to go away.
You need to go away right now.
This Among Us is trolling.
What is this Among Us doing?
Maybe they think the Among Us is a sacrifice.
This Among Us is actually going to troll.
P has a good spot though.
P actually has a good spot up high.
I don't know if I like that spot.
Oh, two are here.
He went down.
I'm going.
Am I leaving?
You're not leaving.
Please.
Please leave.
I'll cry.
Oh my god.
This room is good.
Don't leave.
I'll cry.
Just stay right there.
It's harder in this room when they have speed 2.
I'm not going to lie, Hannah.
Yay, plus 2.
They have speed 2.
Honestly, maybe the corner with Doki is the play.
No, get out.
This is my corner.
Get out.
Doki, you hate teamwork.
This is my...
It's individualism here.
Michael!
It's okay.
We have 4.
Oh my god.
Keep it up.
What's it called?
Died that round.
Orange and yellow.
I don't know.
Shut up.
I'm going into the paint room.
I don't even know what this palace room is.
Wait, what was...
I've never been in this one.
The paint room is good, but it's hard to loop in there.
No, it's not.
No?
Doki, there's grass!
I know, but how much grass though?
I think the corner is always better, Hannah.
Because like...
I agree.
I'm going to the park corner.
We can get a high ground here.
There's only one way in.
You can go across the trapdoors if you need to as well.
What if they don't look up?
Is there a jump boost?
We're in a corner over here.
I think we will have to run eventually.
No Among Us.
Why would you do this to me?
Now I'm definitely going to cry.
Did the Among Us kill you?
No, he's like next to me.
Blue's coming in.
They're chasing somebody.
I can't see.
We need to pivot out of this room.
There's nobody over that way, so we need to pivot out that way.
He's distracted.
There's three here.
Oh my god.
Are they leaving?
No, they're not.
SK, go back to our OG spot.
He didn't see you.
He's looking.
Red is still alive.
SK, you're so good.
Find a safer spot.
That's pretty good.
That is a good spot.
Someone else is coming.
A handsome fella.
He knows.
He's looking for SK.
Oh my god, SK!
Generational.
He had F5!
If he doesn't have F5, I'd win.
Oh my god!
We are doing so good.
Keep it up.
SK, that was unbelievable.
Oh my god, it's the Krusty Krab room.
I don't think we start here.
F5 should be unbinded.
You can get in the head.
There's a jump pad up into this.
I don't know if it's worth it right now.
It's sort of scary.
Wait, what do you mean?
There's literally a skibbity toilet room.
There's a jump pad and you can get in the back of it.
Oh, this room is scary.
Oh my god.
I have a better spot.
I'm chilling.
This spot is not bad.
Play here.
You have to play vision.
Can Michael McChill not troll, please?
Why are you here?
I'm getting out of F5 for this.
You can be in F5, but...
It's hard to see with the wall against us in the background.
Look this way.
Yeah.
Shadoon, please stop jumping.
It's Shadoon and Sleepy.
No, it's Michael McChill.
No, what?
I got trolled by...
I got trolled by a person who was next to me.
He got me killed.
If I see another person, I'm fucking...
I'm leaving.
I got fruit berries.
Oh my god.
This is terrifying.
Oh, they're coming.
They're all coming for you.
I got one on me.
Oh, we have so many.
Oh, my first death.
I wanted to go seven for whatever.
He's right behind you, Addy.
He's right behind you.
There's two.
At least lead them to somebody.
Oh, no.
Why didn't they turn back?
No.
It's okay.
We still have two.
We got this squad.
Wait, Esky, this spot is crazy.
What?
You can literally...
You can jump over the wall if you need to.
This is crazy.
Wait, we will be coming back to this room later.
Yeah, we should go back.
Last round after this.
Yay, Esky.
Yay.
All right, guys.
Last round.
What did they say?
They want to play Simon Says.
I'm good.
That's what you do if you're in bottom half.
I don't know.
That could never be us.
That's crazy.
The room with the stands is really good, by the way.
If you can get up.
There's a really weird library room.
Oh, the library room is good, too.
If you get a high ground in it.
Oh, I found my OP spot.
Do I dare play here again?
Wait, I found my OP spot.
Or maybe.
Maybe they won't look down.
Guys, my last three rounds might not be the best round.
Look, and they're not even playing Simon Says.
They lied.
They killed a bunch.
He almost didn't look down.
Wait, they're actually playing Simon Says.
Well, CPK is hunting.
CPK is hunting.
There's only one person hunting.
We're doing this hunting, and CPK is playing.
Honestly, if I were you guys.
If they're coming to your room, I would just leave and go to a different room.
Because there's only two hunting right now.
It's worth rotating at this point.
I almost got away with it.
Wait, there's another Sonic?
This spot is ridiculous, by the way.
Hannah, come to me.
You see me jumping?
Come here.
No, I'm in a good spot.
SK, come here.
Do this jump pad right here.
There's a jump pad?
Whoa.
What if she dies?
And they can't see you from that door.
If you're coming from that door, you just move over this way.
Wait, they killed them all!
Oh, they killed everybody.
They don't care about charity.
They want it to win.
They don't care.
He tried to kill me last second.
Wow, we survived almost every single round, everyone.
Yeah, we did.
I lived every round, guys.
That might be the highest score.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That might be the best score of all time.
The goat, the goat.
We might have pulled out top two, actually.
That's a dirt strat.
Lock in for a second.
What is the finale game and how do you play it?
It's Valorant.
It's Valorant, but it's meltdown, too.
It's one shot, one kill, Hannah.
Or a breakdown.
So when you're dead, are you dead dead?
No, you can get respawned by teammates.
What is Valorant?
You have to plant a bomb and then they have to defuse it.
It's literally like Valorant or CSGO.
There's two bomb sites and whoever's on attack has to put the bombs down and defend it for like 40 seconds or kill the whole other team.
And if you're on defense, you just need to defend the points and kill the entire team.
Gumi!
Okay, Gumi!
Gumi 10th Indian!
Gumi top 10!
Let's go, Hannah!
I think we made it.
I think we might have made it, actually.
I think we're...
I'll take six.
Yeah!
Guys, I fell off my podium.
Guys!
What should I do?
Should I floss or should I...
You need to floss?
Or T-pose.
I'm doing a T-pose.
Alright, guys.
I'm 99% sure we made it, so lock in.
Do your best.
Oh my god!
Gumi!
Yay!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy too!
Cause you know why.
Oh my god.
That's what you cut out.
First Flock Wars!
That is amazing.
Your first Flock Wars being 13th and this kind of comp is ridiculous.
That is a crazy placement.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Holy shit.
Hopefully I'm A tier now.
Truly.
Sorry, that's cringe.
Sorry.
Alright, lock in, lock in.
We beat out pink.
We already beat out pink.
It's literally us, orange.
I think purple is guaranteed no matter what, right?
Wait, does purple play...
I don't think we're perfect.
Let's go!
We have three FPS players on our team for finals?
Okay, no, no.
I was not doing well.
Wait, you're first.
Orange actually has fallow players, though.
You're a fraud.
Shane, you're a fraud.
They're actually...
Oh my other freaky eye.
Oh no.
Okay, so this A and B site, usually, I don't know if we're an offensive defense, but usually if we're on offense, we're all going to go to one side with maybe one person lurking mid.
You plant bomb and you have to defend it.
Yeah, just plant fast.
It doesn't matter.
I think a lot of what happens in this game that people don't do very well is they give up ground.
So if we're on plant, if we get bombed down, we should keep one or two on site instead of just everybody running back.
Okay, I should play.
I have never played Valorant or CSGO, so yeah.
So essentially, Hannah, I think that if we get a point you should sit on point.
Just rat on point and kill them.
You just kill them.
Wait.
Seven minute break.
I can change my block colors.
Wait, can I go pee?
Do we have time?
Well, I'm going to get a cough drop.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm literally going to be right back.
Okay, I'll be right back as well.
That is ridiculous.
That is insane.
They put us in this at a seven minute break.
That's crazy.
I'm relogging.
Seven minutes?
What?
In the most silent and quiet voice.
Seven minutes?
Wait, Doki.
Doki, are you here?
Escape.
I'm going to send it to AquaVC.
I sent a clip of what happened.
I gotta see this.
Back.
Is it actually seven minutes?
I sent a clip into the VC chat.
Okay.
Wait, I need to change my skin.
This clip might be a bit long.
You might want to skip around, but skip to where it's like 25 seconds.
Okay.
Oh my god, you fell.
Oh my gosh.
I need to turn my aimbot on.
Give me a sec.
It might not work, but like maybe I'm coping.
No way.
Dude, I shut the fuck up.
That's not fair.
You have somebody with 0F5 on?
That's fucked.
Do we have time to change skins?
I changed skins already.
We have seven minutes!
Okay, um...
I'm gonna be a rock.
Oh!
Be a stone block!
Yeah!
Wait, will I be a smooth stone brick block or whatever?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Smooth stone Stone brick skin Minecraft.
Doki, I found one for you.
Okay, I need to change it.
Copy link.
Send to Doki.
Hurry, hurry, because I don't have time.
Wait, can I like...
We have seven minutes, you bitch.
I don't know if seven...
Wait, won't it be easier to hit?
Because like, um...
there's light.
Like, when I stand up...
Look at the walls.
Oh, wait, really?
Okay, I got it.
Okay.
You see it?
Yeah, yeah, I see it.
Okay.
It's time.
We should all just be stones, guys.
I'm just saying.
Have you seen the I am stone challenge?
Oh my god!
He's a diamond block.
No, no, no, don't do it!
You shine!
If you have shaders on, you start shining.
No, you shouldn't!
She's a diamond block!
You actually sparkle!
She's not an actual diamond block!
I don't know!
I'm not in the game!
I don't want her to... I don't want her to sparkle!
Dude, I want to be a redstone block.
Redstone...
Block skin Minecraft.
I fucked up.
I put my... I used my shader ones instead of the actual one.
Download Minecraft skin.
Save.
We just think it's funny.
Oh, I should have been Maria, so Shadow won't shoot me.
Wait, I can still be Maria.
Wait, I'll be Maria.
I've never downloaded this many freaking Minecraft skins before.
Guys, do I do Maria or or a rock?
A rock?
Okay.
Yes, he knows!
He was like, Maria?
I like that.
Guys, do you guys like this?
What's up?
Okay, but this skin will be easier to hit though because she's like blue.
Watch this.
Are you ready?
I'm watching.
Holy fuck, which way is she facing?
Wait, they don't know which way we're facing.
Oh, that's true.
They don't know.
We lose in the end.
We do all night.
And then we're like fucking dweebs.
We're like idiots.
They're like, wow, you guys have derp lock on.
You fucking pirates.
We just did it because we thought it was funny.
They don't even know how much fun we're having.
They think we're sweating.
We're just having fun.
We're sitting in ice rooms hiding things.
Our teammates deafened.
No, they're the ones that are trying.
We're just here to have a good time.
It's okay.
I'm joining their voice channel.
We were here to make sure the team average goes down.
That's fine.
It was too high.
That's why I was here.
It is called block wars.
We're putting the block in block wars.
They should have swapped too.
We could be a block family.
The derp clip goes crazy, Gumi.
They're going to be trying so hard.
We can win this.
I've never played this before.
I don't know which side is better.
B side is always better.
I will say it is very easy to flank on this.
Somebody might come through middle or might come through A.
We just need one person looking at flank.
For defense, I like the play of one person go to one side and all four go to the other side.
I like that too.
I think as a team, for rush B, one person lurk mid.
Who do we go lurking mid?
I think we need Hannah on site with us.
I think it might have to be you.
Is this counter strike?
Look at us.
Counter strike?
Everybody has an AWP and you can rez your teammates.
When you plan it, just stay there.
They have to defuse anyway.
There are a lot of points on site that you can hide on in corners.
You can just rat and hold your bow charge until they are on site.
I'm playing...
Lock in.
If I'm playing anti-flank, I'll try and...
There's a way to rez your teammates.
You have to hold right click on them.
Sometimes it's not worth it.
It's only worth it if you can do it safely.
Are people one shot?
Yes.
Every single shot is one shot.
A lot of them just pre-fire.
This team pre-fires a lot.
I watched last...
Last block wars, this is a very similar team.
These guys won last block wars.
This is site right here.
You see where that lantern is?
You can hide in the corner of site.
People don't check it as much.
If you want to try and rat there.
Doki, I can see a place where you can blend in.
Look.
I think I chose the wrong one.
Right clicking on the heart displayed above their bodies.
When people are down, if you hold down right click on the heart above their body, it will respawn them over time.
It takes a whole 5 seconds though.
Also, I don't think we should plant bomb until we have full site control.
No, plant bomb is very easy to plant bomb and then you don't have to defuse.
I think we all play shooters or games like this.
I think we should plant bomb fast so the timer goes down and it forces them to defuse.
Gumi and I won the last...
Gumi and I won block wars of this.
We have experience with this one.
This is crazy.
What if I sit...
You see this corner right here?
What if I sit there for the flank and just hold mid and A site?
How is this something you can pick here?
Is that a troll spot or no?
I feel like I can watch the flank sort of okay.
I think it's alright.
They show up here.
You can ping.
I feel like, isn't SK going to be the person flanking or whatever?
No, no, no.
I don't have to be.
I think SK should come with us.
I think with authority you have enough firepower to take a site.
One of you have to pick up the charge by the way.
I don't know who but one of you.
What's that?
It's a plant bomb.
I think you should plant bomb.
You have more experience with it.
I can plant.
Oh, we can select which side we want.
I think attack is better.
I think it's a lot harder to start on defense because you don't know what you're doing.
Like, Gumi and I won block wars with attack.
We won this event before.
Didn't you guys win the last one?
The one before the last.
It was like you and Feinberg and Gumi.
Yeah, that was the one I linked for the game.
So one of you pick that up.
I don't know if this spot is good or not.
Is this charged?
Ask Gumi and Doki if the spot is good.
I want to rat right here in the corner.
I think it's alright but most people they rarely flank.
Why would they come all the way back?
I think you can late like mid.
Instead of holding for flank, you just wait a bit.
Don't flank instantly.
I'm fine with you sitting there for like 15 seconds.
Hannah, take off your lunar pets if you have it on you.
They have to approach us.
They just have to push us.
They're in a disadvantage.
If we have bombsite, at least two of you should be on it playing from site.
We just have to hold angles.
This is really far away from both A and B.
If I don't see anybody within a bit I'll rotate over.
Rush B!
Alright Gumi, you plant.
I just have to test it.
When are we first going to see them?
They're not here.
Just plant if you can.
I'm just looking around.
Maybe find a good spot.
That's fine.
Then we can shoot them if they...
I'll tell you if I...
I'm watching some corners and stuff.
But I don't have my... Oh, someone shot.
I see five up.
They're in the thing.
I think they're all there.
I'll start flanking then.
I killed five up.
Should I push?
Just wait.
You don't need to push.
They have to defuse.
I'm going to try and run.
Just stay here.
They're rezzing on the back right.
It takes a long time to defuse.
I got my kill.
That's all you have to do.
You just wait.
Still posted on the back right.
Bomb's planted.
They're going to defuse in time.
Five up is trying to jump shot you.
That's possible.
You just stay.
You just wait.
None of them flanked by the way.
You have to stay flanked just because they will change shots.
I'll stay longer this time.
I think maybe...
They might stack B.
Should we go B again?
I mean...
You want to pause?
Yes.
I think we go A.
You want to go A?
Let's go.
I'll take high ground in the end.
I've never been A though.
I don't know where the plant is.
They're coming A.
Did you plant it though?
I planted.
I don't think I can rez you.
Two flank.
I messed up.
Five up.
I'm bad.
I missed my shot.
I know.
It's just you SK.
It's here.
You don't have to peek.
You don't have to peek SK.
I'm in a corner.
One on spike.
That was my bad.
I messed up the anti-flank.
Five up ran forward and I missed my shot.
Fruit came right behind him.
I saw A site.
I think B is way better.
B is easier.
I get the high ground easily.
We're on defense now.
They get the high ground.
What do we want to do for our defense?
Someone should flank.
3B, 2A.
I think we should go B.
Why did they go A?
Let's go to 3B.
Why are we saying interview?
I don't know.
What do we do here?
We're just preventing them from planting.
3A at least.
I don't see anybody here.
They're B.
They're going to plant.
They're playing in the god spot.
The spot that we had.
3B is holding me mid.
Try and flank them, Ant.
I can't.
3B is holding me.
I'm going to go to you guys instead.
I have to push up.
I got one.
I'm behind you.
You can get me.
3B is out in the open.
He's right here.
He's literally...
Nice.
I'm defusing.
They're all dead.
Really?
Just defuse.
Let's go.
I don't even know where I got shot from.
That was a crazy cross map shot.
I didn't do anything.
3B is holding flank.
It's hard.
You're forcing him to look at that spot.
That's the thing.
I don't have a full commit to a flank.
Unless I want to take a 1v1.
You're forcing him to look at it.
It's fine.
It's just esports.
Yeah.
Should I try and get in a good spot closer up?
Are they A?
I think they went A mid.
Guys, they went A.
I'm rotating.
Where are you mid?
They might be slow rotating.
Michael is mid right now.
I'm coming over.
Just stay.
They're slow rotating.
They're high ground.
That's fine.
They're slow rotating.
They're playing time.
It's fine.
We can play time as well.
Full commit B.
Planet A.
Should we go A?
They're planet A.
If you get up the ladder, you can res me.
They're going to try to res me right now.
I'm on the ladder.
He's trying to res.
Nice.
Road over here.
That's where fruit is.
Fruit's here.
I'm defusing it.
I got him.
They're all dead.
Let's go.
Easy round.
Who flanked behind?
Me.
That was a crazy shot.
Everyone rush B.
I'll take high ground.
I can take high ground.
Someone has to hold for me.
The spawn strategy.
They didn't even...
I'll play in a different spot.
I'm going to stay where I was at last time.
It was a good spot.
I'm going to go where I was at on B.
There's this height spot.
That was my spot.
I see Michael.
I planted for Godspot.
You did.
I'm waiting.
I'm down.
Can someone rez?
You can rez.
I'll look.
I don't see anyone flank yet.
Outside.
They're not defusing.
I'm looking.
I'm going to Godspot.
Are they there?
One's on the bomb.
He's not defusing.
He is.
In the corner.
No!
We did it!
Oh my god!
Let's go!
Oh
my god!
We won for Minecraft!
Let's go!
That's what I'm saying.
We deserved the game.
That was the most generational comeback that we've ever had.
That was generational comeback!
That was such a generational comeback for us.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We have 100% win rate together!
Let's go!
Technically, it's 100% win rate for this block war.
We're going for purple.
We love charity.
That was so good.
Happy skin.
Wait, do we get medals for this?
I did nothing.
We might!
We're going to get medals!
Everyone come close and take a screenshot.
We look so ugly.
I think I look beautiful.
Get over here!
Scoot over.
I had the aim, but I...
Chad, you guys touted me.
If it isn't a fraud.
Well, well, well.
That's right, Chad.
Wait, wait, wait.
Look at our last game.
All of us were top 15 in blitz time, by the way.
Oh my god!
I wonder why.
We just died.
Shane, how did you know I was in the ice most of the time?
As a dirt block.
I saw you when we were voting.
I was like, wait a minute.
And then you guys all were voting.
And I was like, wait a minute.
Do you like our final skins?
Yeah, do you guys like our final skins?
Shane, how do you see the points for...
If you go to the middle.
I'm stuck on this podium.
No, you're not.
Go behind.
Go in the back.
Then you can leave.
You guys were W.
Yeah!
Did we get an interview?
Probably one of you at least.
One of us?
We're a team.
That was a team effort.
You guys did amazing on that.
Goomy, oh my god.
That last game, literally.
I didn't do anything.
I got carried.
I literally did nothing in that game.
That was the FPS player mindset right there.
Dude, three of us are FPS players.
I got so many kills in the last one.
I want to see how long he had left on the defuse.
Shane, I think every single round we had four people alive at minimum.
Yeah, you guys did really well.
Our team, it would just be three of us.
That's gotta be, like, what's Hunt's record on multiplayer.
Surely, it's gotta be.
You guys probably did really well.
Let's take a look over here real quick.
I'm changing my skin.
Wait, is there a...
Wait, I got 14.
Well, you're an OP team, so I don't know about Feinberg, but you got this guy.
It's okay.
They said the entire team can be interviewed.
Yeah, let's go!
Let's go!
Yay!
Winners only!
Oh, my bad.
Actually, I'm gonna...
You know what?
Sorry, I just found a cliff.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god, my stomach hurts.
Maybe you should've been a Minecraft block.
You know what?
I'm kind of a base.
Everyone go, everyone go.
Good job, guys.
Thank you.
Hello!
I gotta fix my webcam.
Oh, wait.
I need to turn on my virtual camera.
I have a face cam.
Guys, I am so happy right now.
Yo, cute!
Wait, I have to fix this.
Oh, my gosh.
Hey, this is me.
Hello!
Wait, I should swap, too.
I should swap here.
Oh, yeah, I'm gonna advertise my gamer stuff, too.
Oh, my god.
I literally advertised my merch.
Yay!
That's a crazy ad.
Did I have a lighting?
It's dark out.
Let's do merch.
Wait, I got another idea.
I gotta advertise multiple things.
Put everything on the screen.
Bro.
Oh,
my god.
Someone asked if they win those medals.
Yeah, yeah, I won the medal.
I'm gonna ask you.
There you go.
That was a good FPS round for me.
I was literally so lost during that game.
I'm not even gonna lie.
I literally killed through for the last kill.
Okay, you're right, guys.
I was like, why are you guys screaming?
You're right, guys.
You're locked in.
It was so stupid.
He was that close to getting it off.
Because he was on it for a while.
Okay, there we go.
Now I have all the things I want to advertise.
Does anyone want to buy ad space?
On my channel?
Yeah, you like the jelly one?
Yeah, hello.
Hello.
Wait, make yourself really large.
You're right, okay.
I need to add a text here, too.
Oh, he was only at 60% defused.
It takes a really long time to defuse.
That's why I said you have to plant fast.
Yeah.
That was a really good callout.
That's how Queenie and I won the last one.
We just planted fast.
So did IGLing.
Yeah.
Let's go.
We knew what's up.
Guys, that redeemed myself from the fucking...
What was it?
The gun game.
That shit was fucking ass for me.
Oh, the deathmatch.
The deathmatch was so bad for me.
And then the Valorant one.
I got so many kills there.
You were bragging.
Oh, oh, photon.
Oh, photon.
I did terrible in extraction.
That was my worst extraction ever.
That was sort of embarrassing, I won't lie.
It's because I was on your team.
I'm cursed.
No, no, no.
I was not playing well.
I promise.
It was me.
Can you believe we came out with top points?
Considering we were in like 6th going into 5th game, no.
I thought we were cucked, I'm not gonna lie.
That battle was so good, though.
Like 6th to 7th or 8th on the reddit.
I think we were like 4th.
I think I said like 4th to 6th.
Yeah, we did so well, guys.
I personally thought we were a top 2 team.
So did I.
I thought we were gonna win the whole time.
I was vibing.
I was like...
I was so happy, dude.
Our battle was beautiful.
Dude, that's why they wanted battle first, because they knew we were gonna do so good.
They were terrified.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy!
We've won so many events together, I feel like.
I know!
Dude, we've won a lot of Twitch rivals together, huh?
And MCC Party.
Yeah, it's like the OP pairing.
Oh my god, is it review time?
They swapped the screen.
I see Cara.
Once we hear them, then we know.
Yeah.
It is Cara.
I love Cara.
Eski, what do you wanna do after this?
What game do you wanna play?
I think Doki has to play Fortnite.
I'm a little bit late for my sponsor.
You're late too now.
But it's okay.
I'm gonna get a Twitch Rivals medal.
You wanna try Deadlocked?
Yeah, let's play Deadlocked.
You wanna play that?
Oh, I do wanna try that one game that SageM and then play...
Oh, he's super high.
Every single team had a crazy good...
sometimes two crazy good players.
And the fact that the Aqua Archers, I think they just got really, really lucky with the game selection.
Wait,
wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm calling at strategy at just PvP in general.
So I think just that really helped boost their morale at least going into game 8 where BlitzHunt while they didn't hunt much better than everyone else, they were Huh?
I got four people.
Okay.
I got two.
It's good, it's good.
I think the main thing about the team, obviously you can point to Hanna and Aphrox, but I think everyone stepped up.
I mean, we saw the clip of Gumi there.
We know how good SK is at other video games that aren't Minecraft that are team-based to be able to perform in this atmosphere.
And DokiBird actually in a recent block wars had played in a shockwave and actually got the final kill.
That's me!
That's my goat.
What the fuck?
She literally was there at our interview at the beginning of our show.
Oh, I was there.
They stayed under the radar enough they stayed on the edge enough to be in contention.
Yeah, we did that on purpose.
That's the scariest thing we did, man.
Yeah, we inted early on purpose.
Yeah, we inted early on purpose to scale.
That's gotta be a game of chicken that is a real difficult thing to maneuver.
Absolutely.
I wonder if them just like not...
Like, I don't think they were waiting to show their skills at all but the fact that...
What the hell?
We're getting cut in the core retweets now.
We're losing the interview.
Yeah,
it was... We pretended to be bad guys so they won.
Guys, it was all acting.
When I was 37th place in the race, I pretended to be bad there.
You're welcome.
Azaz!
Hi!
Oh my god!
You can be honest because quite frankly, you are incredible but this is a scary lobby for so many people.
You know what?
I thought we had a lot of potential to do really, really, really well.
Like so much potential because really our team covers all the bases.
Specifically, Doki, Gumi, and Esker are really good at the things I'm really bad at.
Like the finale game, that was amazing.
But when it came to battle and Blitz Hunt in the final two games, like I knew.
I knew that we had a chance to make it to the top two.
I was 99% sure.
Because those are our best games by far.
So I was pretty confident at that point.
You know, you should have been.
Clearly, it showed.
I love it.
Yeah, I have a question for like especially Gumi, Esker, and Doki.
Like you guys...
Don't...
Y'all are playing Minecraft too much.
But like when you play a bunch of other games, do you think your skills in other games kind of helped to achieve this victory?
Let's go with Esker first.
Oh, definitely.
Yes.
Yeah, we definitely for like the last one because we're both playing FPS games.
So we were like oh, we know how to do this because at first we were like the original strat was to go in fast.
But Gumi, me, and Esker were like no, no, no.
We just plant the bomb and we wait because that's basically Valorant.
You just wait and wait for them to push us because we have the corner advantage.
So we just used our knowledge from other video games for that.
That's why it was so easy for us.
You're not Esker.
Oh, you said Esker.
Okay, Esker, you can go too.
Oh no.
You said everything that I would say.
Yes, it helps a lot.
I guess it's your turn, Gumi.
Yeah, it's your turn.
Oh.
Yeah, it helped.
Don't you said it all.
I have nothing more to say.
I think my favorite was us changing skins.
See, we played other video games and we knew the act of camouflage.
Yeah, yeah, we knew.
We knew.
We were like, oh my, that's why people, you know, grind for cosmetics because they gotta have the sweaty skins.
But Minecraft, it's free.
We can log out and change our skins whenever we want.
That was insane.
I feel like that actually helped us a lot though.
Because they don't know what is real.
Having a diamond block?
They don't know what you're facing, Esker.
They were like, which one's front and which one's back.
Our biggest strength is that we were just having fun.
We had nothing to lose.
No stakes.
We were just having a blast.
That's so true.
Our battle.
We had, I think, double the points than anybody else in battle.
Which is, I've never seen that before.
That was amazing.
I don't know if you guys know, but we showed it on the broadcast like, you had so many more capture points than everyone else.
The way you played it was just dominating in that fashion.
It was really cool to see.
And I think it really paid off.
It obviously did.
Yeah, that was all Antfrost.
That's not true.
That's our IGL.
Fine.
GG's!
Bye bye!
I'm gonna go back to Aqua channel.
Oh my god, they cut off all my ads.
Yeah, that's funny though.
I legitimately didn't hear that they said SK first.
I thought they asked all of us.
So I was like, no one's saying anything.
No one said anything.
You saved me.
I had nothing to say.
Yeah, because I was like, no one said anything.
So then I was like, okay.
And then they're like, you're not SK.
I was like, what?
I said that.
Yeah!
GG's, guys.
GG's.
Have fun with Fortnite.
Yeah, I gotta go to my Fortnite sponsor now.
GG's, everybody.
It was great playing with you guys.
We're the block...
The block girls.
We committed to the block.
What?
You don't like the block girls?
We're the block girls!
Fortnite man.
Bye-bye.
I can't believe...
I still can't believe...
Um...
I can't believe...
I got ad blocked.
They literally skipped my ad.
I can't believe it.
Bro, I legitimately...
Cause like...
It was like 3 seconds of no one saying anything.
And then like...
And then...
And then I was like...
Okay, I guess I'll go first.
And then...
No!
I was...
Confused.
That was fun.
Actually, I legitimately did not expect this.
Yeah, I didn't hear him say SK.
But yeah.
I legitimately didn't hear them say that.
But yeah, I'm late.
I'm gonna be late for Fortnite.
I'll start at like 6.30.
Cause I want a little bit of chill time.
Or 6.45.
Cause I want a little bit of chill time before I go in.
But I did not...
Expect...
I did not expect...
To win.
But I hope we do get the Twitch Rival medals.
I'm gonna message.
Do we get...
Do we get the Twitch...
Do we get sent Twitch Rival medals?
For winning?
I messaged.
Cause I'm curious.
But yeah!
GG's!
GG's everybody!
Chill time.
By the way, I have a Fortnite creator code.
If you guys didn't know.
There's 24 hours left before this is gone.
Gone forever!
So yeah, we have 24 hours left.
Before the gamer stuff is pulled off.
And you won't be able to get it after that.
Because it's very limited.
And what other things?
I don't really remember.
Oh yes, please.
I mean, guys.
Come on, guys.
That was FPS right there.
That was FPS VTuber right there.
For that last game.
Like, come on guys.
Did we or did we not...
Fucking killed so many people.
We carried that game so hard.
The last round.
That should be a vote right there.
In the VTuber awards.
And other than that.
I guess.
The Phantom Thief concert.
Is next week.
On Saturday.
So make sure.
Oh my gosh.
I'm like so...
My hands are like all over the place right now.
Where is it?
VTuber.
Oh, I can't believe.
I thought it was so funny that they cut.
That they cut up all my ass.
We were all like...
We all saw it too.
We were just looking at it.
And I was like.
No.
But anyway.
They said no ass.
But yes.
And we have.
We also are nominated for VTuber of the year.
I feel like that moment should have been.
That cements VTuber of the year for me.
Come on.
That moment should have cemented it.
Anyway guys.
I'm going to see you guys.
On YouTube.
For those who are new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check my channel out there.
I would tweet out.
Whenever I'm live on Twitch.
So please follow me on Twitter.
If you want to support me via other means.
There's all that other stuff I just showed.
As well as my store.
My merch store.
But yeah.
I also have a custom PC set.
From Hyatt.
So you can buy.
If you want a custom PC case.
From me.
That's me.
You can check out Hyatt.
I'm going to head off to Fortnite now.
I'll be streaming in 15 minutes.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause, check.
Get up and move around.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Where's the ending screen?
Oh there it is.
Bye.